I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Today we are talking about the Valentine's Day episode. I am so excited for this one. Me too, I liked this one so much, I watched it an extra time in my prep just for pleasure.
我是詹娜·菲舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室名媛。今天我们要聊的是情人节那一集。我对这一集期待已久。我也是，我太喜欢这一集了，在做准备工作时，为了享受我又多看了一遍。
I did too. My husband, Josh was like, babe, how many times are you gonna watch that episode? I was like, I am really enjoying it. I think this one sneaked up on me because there are certain episodes that I remember as being favorites. Yeah. And this one was not on my radar.
我也是。我丈夫乔什说，宝贝，你打算看那集多少遍？我说，我真的很享受。我觉得这一集悄悄惊艳到我了，因为有些剧集我记得是我的最爱。是的。而这一集之前并不在我的雷达范围内。
And then I watched it and so many memories came back to you. So many. Okay, this is a goodie. This is season two, episode 16, written by Mike Schur and directed by Greg Daniels. I mean, honestly, that's all you need to know right there. That's like the super team. Yeah, of course this is a great one. All right, honestly, that's all you need to know. Right there. That team. Yeah, of course this is a great one. All right, I'll give a summary. It's Valentine's Day at Dunder Mifflin. Michael has to go to the corporate offices in New York. He has to meet and do a
然后我看完了，好多回忆都涌上心头。真的好多。好吧，这一集太棒了。这是第二季第16集，由迈克·舒尔编剧，格雷格·丹尼尔斯导演。说实话，有这些信息就足够了。这就像是超级梦幻团队。是的，这当然是一集极好的剧。好吧，说实话，你只需要知道这些。就在那里。那个团队。是的，这当然是一集极好的剧。好吧，我来总结一下。邓德米夫林迎来了情人节。迈克尔必须去纽约的公司总部。他必须去会见并做一场
presentation for the new CFO, Chief Financial Officer. It's a big deal. It is. And he's going to be there with Jan on Valentine's Day. Oh no. Back at the office, Phyllis is overwhelmed by gifts from her boyfriend Bob Vance, Advanced Refrigeration. They just come all day, these gifts. All day. Pam patiently waits for a gift from Roy that never comes. No, no.
面向新首席财务官（CFO）的演讲。这可是件大事。确实是。而且他要在情人节那天和简在那里见面。哦，不。回到办公室，菲利斯被她的男友鲍勃·万斯（万斯冷气公司）送来的礼物搞得应接不暇。这些礼物一整天都在送来。一整天。潘耐心地等待着罗伊的礼物，却始终没有等到。不，不。
And she really dolled herself up. Oh yes, that's my fast fact number one, Angela. Do it, do it. Fan question from Baltimore Ashley, what was the thought process behind Pam's hair for this episode? Was there another special meeting? I bet there was.
而且她真的精心打扮了一了一番。哦，是的，那是我的第一条冷知识，安吉拉。说吧，说吧。来自巴尔的摩的粉丝阿什利提问，这集中潘的发型背后有什么构思吗？是不是还有另一个特别会议？我敢说肯定有。
Oh my gosh, you guys, I also got similar questions from Casey McMillan and many other people asking if there was a special meeting for Pam's hair. There was more than a meeting. It was like the Joint Chiefs of Staff. It was. Came together for your hair.
哦，天哪，伙计们，我也收到了来自凯西·麦克米兰和许多其他人的类似问题，他们都在问是不是为潘的发型开过一个特别会议。那可不止是一个会议。简直就像参谋长联席会议。确实是。为了你的头发齐聚一堂。
So the thought process here was that Pam and Jim in this episode, they're gonna be a bit estranged. So wouldn't it be an extra nail in the coffin for Jim if Pam just looked super duper cute? Right. So we thought, can we please do something different with her hair? I had a MySpace blog at the time and I wrote about my hair. And I said that Kim Ferry and I worked for weeks on different versions of this look. Well, knowing Kim Ferry like I do, like you do, she must have been so excited. She was so good at hair, but she never got to do much with our hair. No. Okay, so here's what we tried. We tried a ponytail, a barrette, and headbands.
所以这里的构思是，潘和吉姆在这集中关系会有点疏远。那么，如果潘看起来超级无敌可爱，对吉姆来说会不会是雪上加霜呢？没错。所以我们想，能不能请为她的头发做点不一样的造型？我当时有一个MySpace博客，我还在上面写了我的头发。我说吉姆·费里和我花了数周时间研究这款造型的不同版本。不过以我对吉姆·费里的了解，就像你了解的那样，她当时一定兴奋极了。她做发型非常厉害，但她从没怎么有机会帮我们做头发。没有。好吧，所以我们尝试了这些：我们尝试了马尾辫、发夹和发带。
We took a picture of each choice and we presented them to Greg Daniels. And he went through the photos and had to pick hairstyle and he picked the headband. And there were various headbands. Now, what I say, what I say, headbands. Were there 12 different headbands? Yes, yes.
我们给每种选择都拍了照片，然后把它们呈交给格雷格·丹尼尔斯。他翻看了这些照片，必须挑出一个发型，而他选了发带。而且有各种各样的发带。现在，我说的是，我说的是，发带。是不是有12种不同的发带？是的，是的。
So it was, and also ponytails, high pony, low pony, side pony. No, side pony. Well, side pony, low pony, side pony. No side pony. Well, side pony shows up later at the art fair. I wore a side ponytail to my prom. I think it was my senior year I did a side pony. I was not cool, guys. You did a side pony to prom? Yeah, I did a side.
所以它是，还有马尾辫，高马尾，低马尾，侧马尾。不，侧马尾。嗯，侧马尾，低马尾，侧马尾。没有侧马尾。嗯，侧马尾后来在艺术展上出现了。我参加毕业舞会时扎过侧马尾。我想那是我高三的时候，我扎了个侧马尾。我当时可真不酷，伙计们。你扎着侧马尾去参加毕业舞会？对啊，我扎了个侧马尾。
Did you get that done at a salon or did you do that at home? No, my mom did it. My mom did it and that was the year the year before we had all had dates and none of us had a good time. My group of like really close girlfriends. Yeah. So that was the year the guys thought they were being really cool and they're like, we're not going to take dates this year. I went to a small school and so the girls were like, fine. And we had the best time. Was it your senior prom? Our senior prom. I danced in a circle with all my girlfriends with a side ponytail.
那是你在美发沙龙弄的，还是你在家里自己弄的？没有，我妈给我弄的。我妈给我弄的，那是一年前的那一年，我们当时都有舞伴，但谁也没玩开心。我那一群非常要好的女朋友。对。所以那是男生们自以为很酷的一年，他们说，我们今年不带舞伴了。我读的是一所小学校，所以女生们就想，好吧。我们玩得开心极了。那是你们的高中毕业舞会吗？我们的毕业舞会。我扎着侧马尾，和所有的女朋友围成一圈跳舞。
Lady, I did an all girls prom for my senior prom too. You did. We would have been in the same dance circle. We would have. You would have loved my side pony. I have a card about that fast fact. Tell it. I mean, not only is it Pam's hair, Pam is wearing a pink sweater, her headband's pink, she has
天哪，我的高中毕业舞会也是全女生的舞会。真的吗。那我们会在同一个跳舞圈子里。我们会的。你会喜欢我的侧马尾的。我有一张卡片是关于那个冷知识的。讲讲吧。我的意思是，不仅是潘的头发，潘穿着一件粉色毛衣，她的发带是粉色的，她戴着
a heart necklace on, she has pink earrings on. I mean- Little pink dangle earrings. I know, the lady came, like she came to be noticed. She did, she's, I think a little lip gloss? Yes. It was a whole look. I have to say, when I first saw myself on screen, I was a little bit like, oh,
一条心形项链，她戴着粉色耳环。我的意思是——小巧的粉色吊坠耳环。我知道，这女的来的时候，就像她是来引人注目的。没错，她来了，我觉得她还涂了一点唇彩？是的。整个造型很完整。我不得不说，当我第一次在屏幕上看到自己时，我有点像，哦，
oh, Pam, Pam went for it. Pam showed up today. And I mean, I mean, it's going to play out later in the episode. But like, Roy, come on, this is someone who clearly wants to Valentine. So no matter what she says. Okay, sorry. Fast fact number two, fast fact number two, a portion of this episode was shot in New York City. We got a lot of fan questions about this. People wanted to know if we did Steve stand in front of a green screen, did we shoot on the streets of Los Angeles?
哦，潘，潘豁出去了。潘今天盛装出席了。我的意思是，我的意思是，这在集数后面会慢慢铺陈开来。但是，罗伊，拜托，这是一个明显想要过情人节的人。所以不管她说什么。好吧，抱歉。第二条冷知识，第二条冷知识，这一集的一部分是在纽约市拍摄的。我们收到了很多关于这部分的粉丝提问。人们想知道我们是不是让史蒂夫站在绿幕前拍的，还是我们在洛杉矶的街道上拍摄的？
No, but there's more questions, Angela. Fan question from Cora Louise, how many crew members came to New York City? And Guava Aora asked, how long did it take to shoot this episode in New York and was the rest of the cast in California? Yes. We did not get to go. We did not.
没有，但还有更多问题，安吉拉。来自科拉·路易斯的粉丝提问，有多少剧组人员来到了纽约市？瓜娃·奥拉问，在纽约拍摄这集花了多长时间，其余演员是在加利福尼亚吗？是的。我们没能去。我们没有。
We were all pretty bummed because it sounded like so much fun. So I reached out to Randall Einhorn, our director of photography. Jenna, you know I did this. I know. And you guys, she wouldn't tell me what he said. She's got all this good information about the New York shoot and she made me wait.
我们所有人都挺失落的，因为听起来太有趣了。所以我联系了我们的摄影指导兰德尔·艾恩霍恩。詹娜，你知道我这么做了。我知道。而且你们这些家伙，她不肯告诉我他说的话。她掌握了所有关于纽约拍摄的好料，却让我干等。
Well, this is something we do. We both love to like dig up nuggets of info and then we don't tell each other because we want the surprise. I know, well, I've still been waiting like five days for this. Okay, here we go. So I reached out to Randall and he said the crew in New York was just him and Greg and Steve.
好吧，这是我们常做的事。我们俩都喜欢搜集一些信息边角料，然后又不对彼此保密，因为我们想要那种惊喜感。我知道，好吧，为了这个我已经等了大约五天了。好吧，我们开始吧。所以我联系了兰德尔，他说在纽约的剧组只有他、格雷格和史蒂夫。
That would go out on the street when they would film. And in the van they had like, I think two crew members that were New York based like, because they had to do things by the rules, you know, and our line producer, Kent Zabornak. But whenever the van doors would open, it would just be Greg, Steve and Randall. He said that this was right at the height of 40 year old Virgin. It was the biggest movie in America. He said there was a billboard in Times Square where they were filming. So he said the minute Steve would get out of the van, a crowd would form.
他们拍摄时会去街上。在面包车里，大概有，我想有两名纽约本地的剧组人员，因为他们必须按规矩办事，你知道的，还有我们的制片主任肯特·扎博纳克。但每当面包车门打开时，就只有格雷格、史蒂夫和兰德尔。他说这正值《四十岁的老处男》大火的时候。那是美国最卖座的电影。他说他们拍摄的地方时代广场上就有一块广告牌。所以他说史蒂夫一从面包车里出来，人群就会聚集起来。
So he said they had to move really fast and quickly. And he said he used a handy cam camera, like a basic handy cam camera that you could buy at Costco. Whoa. It's a really small camera, so not to draw a lot of attention to them. Yeah. Because the minute people saw Steve, literally he said a crowd would form. Well, wasn't this also right after his Golden Globe win? Oh, yes.
所以他说他们必须行动得非常快。而且他说他用了一台手持摄像机，就像你在好市节点的那种基础款手持摄像机。哇。那是一台非常小的摄像机，为的是不引起大家的太多注意。对。因为人们一看到史蒂夫，字面意思上他就说人群就会聚拢。好吧，这不也正好是在他赢得金球奖之后吗？哦，是的。
Yes, it was all of that. He just won the Golden Globe. There was a billboard of him in Times Square, and they're going to film on the streets of New York. Bonkers. Bonkers. Now, this was a billboard of him in Times Square, and they're going to film on the streets of New York. Bonkers. Bonkers. Now, this was scripted, though. They had certain scripted spots, but I know that Steve was also improvising and riffing
是的，就是那段时间。他刚刚赢得金球奖。时代广场上有他的巨幅广告牌，而他们要在纽约街头拍摄。太疯狂了。太疯狂了。不过，这是有剧本的。他们有特定的有剧本的镜头，但我知道史蒂夫当时也在即兴发挥和胡诌
at the same time. It was very loosey-goosey. That's true. That's true. So I asked Randall, okay, what were some of the things that you know were scripted? He said the Rockefeller Center portion was scripted. He said that Sabaro was scripted, but he said that he's pretty sure when Steve goes
同时进行。非常随意。确实如此。确实如此。所以我问兰德尔，好吧，你知道哪些是剧本里写好的？他说洛克菲勒中心的那部分是有剧本的。他说萨巴罗（Sbarro）那段是有剧本的，但他很确信当史蒂夫走进
into the subway and sees a man pooping in the box, that was improv, that was Steve just goofing around. But Steve did a lot of improv. Like whenever they saw something or they had a moment he would hop out, you know, there's a tag at the end of like the Fiddler on the roof, like him goofing around. That's improv. There's a bunch of deleted scenes of him on the streets
地铁并看到一个男人在盒子里便便时，那是即兴发挥，那是史蒂夫在瞎胡闹。但史蒂夫做了很多即兴发挥。比如每当他们看到什么或者有什么时刻他就会跳出来，你知道的，就像《屋顶上的提琴手》最后有个彩蛋，他瞎胡闹。那是即兴发挥。有很多关于他在纽约街头的被删减片段
of New York that I think are a lot of improvisations. They're fantastic. The deleted scenes for this are great, and I'll bring up some more of them later. And then I said, Randall, is there like a fun story or a memory you have from filming in New York that maybe doesn't even have anything to do with the episode? And he said, yes. This is what he said. He said the night they got into New York,
我觉得有很多即兴发挥。它们太棒了。这一集的删减片段很棒，我待会儿会多聊一些。然后我说，兰德尔，你在纽约拍摄时有没有什么有趣的故事或回忆，可能甚至跟这一集都没什么关系？他说，有。他是这么说的。他说他们到达纽约的当晚，
just him and Steve went to this place called Johnny's and they got beer and pizza. He said he thought the pizza was pepperoni. But he just said it was really special and they were walking back to their hotel, walking through Times Square. And he said there were billboards everywhere, a 40-year-old virgin with Steve's face like all over the place and the show is getting popular. Steve had just won a Golden Globe so it was kind of surreal to walk through all of those, you know, billboards of Steve. And people started coming up to Steve and Randall said that Steve was as gracious and kind to the first person who stopped him as he was to the 100th. He just was so kind and in the moment. But that is Steve, you know?
只有他和史蒂夫去了一个叫强尼的地方，他们喝了啤酒，吃了披萨。他说他以为那个披萨是意大利辣香肠味的。但他只是说这非常特别，他们走回酒店，穿过时代广场。他说到处都是广告牌，到处都是《四十岁的老处男》史蒂夫的脸，而且这部剧越来越受欢迎。史蒂夫刚赢得金球奖，所以走在所有那些，你知道的，史蒂夫的广告牌中间，感觉有点超现实。人们开始走向史蒂夫，兰德尔说史蒂夫对待第一个拦住他的人和对待第一百个拦住他的人一样亲切温和。他就是那么和善，活在当下。但这就是史蒂夫，你知道的吗？
He is so kind and gracious. And Randall just said it was really special. I think for him and Steve to just have that night together like that, just grabbing a slice and a beer and being in New York, I'm sure it felt really cool. Aw, I love that. I know, me too. That's one of the cool things about the show where there's some circumstance
他是那么的温和亲切。兰德尔只是说这真的很特别。我想对他和史蒂夫来说，能有那样一个属于彼此的夜晚，去吃块披萨喝杯啤酒，身处纽约，那种感觉肯定酷极了。哇，我喜欢这个。我知道，我也是。这是这部剧很酷的特色之一，总有一些环境
that brings you to an experience you would not have normally had. Yeah, yeah. So cool, so cool. And Greg and Kent Zbornak talk a little bit more about New York and the DVD commentary, so if you wanna give that a listen. All right, Jenna, that's my New York City nuggets.
会带给你一种平时根本不会有的经历。对啊，对啊。太酷了，太酷了。格雷格和肯特·扎博纳克在DVD评论音轨里还多聊了一些关于纽约的内容，如果你想听的话可以去听听。好吧，詹娜，这就是我的纽约市花絮。
They were great and they were worth waiting for. Thank you. I loved them. Thank you. Fast fact number three. In this episode, we meet the new CFO of Dunder Mifflin, David Wallace. Hey now.
它们太棒了，绝对不枉我等这么久。谢谢你。我很喜欢。谢谢你。第三条冷知识。在这一集中，我们见到了邓德米夫林的新任首席财务官大卫·华莱士。嘿。
Hey. Who's here? Hey now. Andy Buckley. There we go. Who's in studio with us now. I'm going to put on the Wallace glasses. Put on the Wallace glasses.
嘿。谁来了？嘿。安迪·巴克利。我们到了。现在谁和我们一起在录音室里。我要戴上华莱士眼镜了。戴上华莱士眼镜。
Put on the Wallace glasses. It's really bam. Andy, you heard in 37 episodes of the show. Yep. 37. That's crazy, yeah. Here's some stuff I learned about you by looking you up on the internet. Well, get ready.
戴上华莱士眼镜。真的太棒了。安迪，你听说了吗，你出演了该剧的37集。对。37集。太疯狂了，是啊。这里有一些我在互联网上搜索你时了解到的关于你的事情。好吧，准备好吧。
We should say the three of us are friends in real life. Yes. So it was a little bit interesting to Google a friend. Yeah. But here's some things I learned about you. None of it is true. Oh boy. But it's probably all good to know. It's probably all true.
我们应该先说明，我们三个在现实生活中是朋友。是的。所以去谷歌搜索一个朋友感觉有点意思。是的。但以下是我了解到的关于你的一些事情。全都是假的。哦，天哪。不过可能都是些好消息。可能全都是真的。
You were born in Boston. Yep. Salem, Massachusetts grew up in Marblehead, Swampskate, Peabody, mostly Marblehead. And I have the SmartPak. You do? You do? John Krasinski, SmartPak. You graduated from Stanford University. Yeah.
你在波士顿出生。对。马萨诸塞州的塞勒姆，在马布尔黑德、斯旺斯凯特、皮伯迪长大，大部分时间在马布尔黑德。我还有SmartPak。你有吗？你有的？约翰·卡拉辛斯基，SmartPak。你毕业于斯坦福大学。对。
But you got a degree in political science. Yes, that was. Not theater, not acting. No, so I did, I was a golfer in high school and I went there to play golf. Like I was on the golf team. Like on a golf scholarship? Yeah, they didn't have a ton of money,
但你拿的是政治学学位。是的，那是。不是戏剧，不是表演。对，所以我，我高中是个高尔夫球手，我去那里是为了打高尔夫。就像我是高尔夫球队的。拿着高尔夫奖学金吗？对，他们没有很多钱，
but I got in through the golf program and they gave you a thousand bucks. You're a good golfer. I used to be, I'm still good, but I used to be. But yes, and I was a polycymer. I did plays there and I had done plays in high school also and loved acting and saw a James Dean movie when I was in high school and thought I was gonna be
但我通过高尔夫项目进去了，他们给了我一千块钱。你是个优秀的高尔夫球手。我以前是，我现在技术也还可以，但以前确实是。不过是的，我曾是个政治学专业的学生。我在那儿演过话剧，我在高中时也演过话剧，非常热爱表演，我上高中的时候看过一部詹姆斯·迪恩的电影，以为自己会成为
like a brooding young. Brooding, golf playing. Yes, yes. James Dean. All of the above. Political science. And none of it. James Dean.
那种忧郁的年轻人。忧郁的、打高尔夫的。是的，是的。詹姆斯·迪恩。以上皆是。政治学。全都不搭界。詹姆斯·迪恩。
But when you were cast on the show. Yeah. You were working as a wealth management advisor. Yeah. Which I believe is a fancy word for stockbroker. That's exactly it. Yeah. At Merrill Lynch.
但当你被选中出演这部剧时。对。你当时正在做财富管理顾问。对。我想这是一个听起来很高大上的词，也就是股票经纪人。完全正确。是的。在美林证券。
Yes. I study acting. I moved to Los Angeles. It does not go well for the first like seven or eight or nine years. I get little bits and pieces here. Allison Jones being possibly my only fan, luckily. And my wife, who was then my girlfriend, said, you got to change it up? This is crazy.
是的。我学表演。我搬到了洛杉矶。头七八九年左右，一切都不顺利。我在那里零零碎碎接点小活。艾莉森·琼斯可能是我唯一的粉丝，很幸运。当时还是我女朋友的妻子对我说，你得换个活法！这太疯狂了。
Like you can't just keep doing these odd jobs and then think you're gonna get hired, blah, blah. She was like, get a job. Get a job. Literally, basically get a job. And there was an old acting buddy of mine who was working there and he would still audition. He said, oh, come interview.
就是说你不能一直干这些杂七杂八的工作，然后还指望被录用，巴拉巴拉。她就像是，去找个工作。找个工作。字面意思，基本上就是去找个工作。我有一个以前的表演老搭档在那儿工作，他平时还会去试镜。他说，哦，来面试吧。
Are you, might be great for you. And they hire me and I, you know, I loved it. It was crazy. I loved it. So I started there in 2001 and was there and that's all I was doing. And then we got married and we had our first son. I bumped into Alison Jones. We're like the local farmers market on large month.
你，这可能很适合你。然后他们录用了我，我，你知道的，我很喜欢。太疯狂了。我很喜欢。所以我2001年在那儿开始工作，一直待在那儿，那是我当时唯一在做的事。然后我们结婚了，有了我们的第一个儿子。我碰巧遇到了艾莉森·琼斯。我们在大蒙思的当地农贸市场。
And you're, you're, you're a stengrocracker. And I'm just a guy getting up and being in the office at six and talking to clients or potential clients. And I see her and what are you doing, Buckley? Haven't seen you in a while. I'm like, stock broker, married, I got a kid. I got like Mr. Grownup. She says, well, give me your car just in case
而你，你，你是个证券经纪人。而我只是个早上六点起床去办公室和客户或潜在客户交谈的普通人。我看到了她，最近怎么样，巴克利？好久不见。我说，股票经纪人，结婚了，有个孩子。我简直成了个成年人先生。她说，好吧，把你的名片给我，以防
something comes up, you never know. I mean, would you want to do it? I can't, sure. I me your card just in case something comes up. You never know. I mean, would you want to do it? I can't, sure. I guess if it's in town and without her mentioning anything or thinking, you know, four months almost later, she calls me. It's like, Buckley, I can't believe I found this card, but I'm glad I did. I think you might be the right guy. You should come audition for this, you know, the boss on the office, you know, the show.
有什么机会出现，你永远说不准。我是说，你想不想试试？我当然愿意。把你的名片给我，以防万一有什么事。你永远说不准。我是说，你想不想试试？我当然愿意。我想如果是在城里拍而且她什么也没提或者压根没想，你知道的，差不多四个月后，她给我打电话了。就像是，巴克利，真不敢相信我找到了这张名片，但我很高兴我找到了。我觉得你可能是对的人。你应该来试镜这个角色，你知道的，《办公室》里的老板，你知道那部剧吗？
And it's like, yeah, of course I know the show. Like, yeah, he's the financial guy and you're a financial guy. They might like that, you should audition. And it was great. So I go in and say hi, do the first scene. But I read with Allison, it was Mike Schur in the room and it was just the two of them.
然后就像，对，我当然知道这部剧。就像，对，他是搞财务的，你也是搞财务的。他们可能会喜欢这个，你应该来试镜。这太棒了。所以我走进去打招呼，演了第一场戏。但我跟艾莉森对戏，迈克·舒尔也在房间里，当时就他们俩。
So I read with Allison, I do the first scene and then the second scene. And then Michael says, now you're like, you're a finance. What do you, you're like some kind of financial guy, right? Nice. Now, knowing Mike the way we know Mike, he loved that. I know that he loved that, that you were actually working at Merrill Lynch was probably one of the coolest things
所以我跟艾莉森对戏，演了第一场戏，然后是第二场戏。接着迈克尔说，现在你就像是个，你是搞财务的。你是个，你是什么财务方面的人，对吧？太棒了。现在，以我们对迈克的了解，他很喜欢这个。我知道他很喜欢这个，你实际上在美林证券工作，对他来说可能是最酷的事情之一
to him. I figure that's why I got hired. And then I go back to my office and I'm like, all right. And you just go about your day and then the next morning, Allison calls and says, hey, they're gonna hire you. And it was so, I was so excited. It was like, oh man, this'll be awesome. And at the time I thought, well, maybe like,
我想这就是我被录用的原因。然后我回到办公室心想，好吧。然后你就继续过你的一天，接着第二天早上，艾莉森打电话说，嘿，他们要录用你。当时我太兴奋了。就像是，哦，天哪，这太棒了。当时我想，好吧，也许
I guess it'll be cool. I'll get to be on this show like once a year or something like that or twice. I mean, that'll be fun. And- Yeah, I was gonna ask you, when you auditioned, did they say this was one episode with the possibility of more or did they give you any indication that this might lead to 37 episodes?
我想这挺酷的。我能一年左右在这部剧里露面一次或者几次什么的。我的意思是，那会挺有意思的。而且——是的，我正想问你，当你试镜时，他们有没有说过这是一集客串，以后可能还会有，还是给了你任何暗示这可能会演变成37集？
No, they didn't say anything. And that was it. It was so whatever day the audition was and then the next week, I guess, I did it. Now where did you film the boardroom scenes? My memory is that it was right next to our Dunder Mifflin set, that you could walk from our set to your set. Right, that's what it was, yeah. So you were just right there?
不，他们什么都没说。就是这样。不管试镜是哪天，然后我想第二周我就去演了。话说你在哪拍的董事会场景？我的记忆中，它就在我们邓德米夫林片场的隔壁，你可以从我们的片场走到你的片场。对，就是那样，没错。所以你就在那附近？
I was right there and I show up and Steve couldn't have been nicer. Everybody, you know, everybody couldn't have been nicer. And it was just, it was fun because Greg would come up and he would say, Steve couldn't have been nicer everybody you know everybody couldn't have been nicer and and And and it was just it was fun because Greg would come up and he would say great. That was good Okay, and let's try it this way and he would have an idea which I can't I was trying to think like what were his Specific ideas and it was along the lines of like do this one as if you just want to keep things calm Do this one as if you're a little irritated. Do and he just sort of subtle, subtle changes.
我就在那附近，我一到那儿，史蒂夫态度好得不得了。每个人，你知道的，每个人的态度都好得不得了。而且很有趣，因为格雷格会走过来，他说，史蒂夫态度好得不得了，每个人，你知道的，每个人的态度都好得不得了，而且，而且，而且，而且这很有趣，因为格雷格走过来会说，太棒了。那很好，好，我们换个方式试一下。他会有个想法，我当时在想，他的具体想法是什么来着？大致意思是，把这段演得就像你只想保持冷静一样。把这段演得就像你有点被激怒了一样。做，他就给出那种微妙的、微妙的改变。
This is in the great scope, you know, when he shows the video. Oh my goodness, you guys, your facial reactions to the video that Michael makes is so amazing. It was so wonderful. So when do you get the call that they want you back for another episode? A year later. A year later? Oh my gosh, Andy. Oh, it's great. Allison calls and says, Buckley, you're in an episode in a couple of weeks and you're all over it. Like you're having a party at your house. Everybody's there. It's crazy. And she's like, J.J. Abrams is directing. Like it's crazy. You're like, wait, I have some meetings I have to rearrange.
这是在大局上，你知道的，当他播放视频的时候。哦，天哪，伙计们，你们对迈克尔制作的视频的面部反应太精彩了。太美妙了。那么你是什么时候接到电话说他们想让你回归再拍一集的？一年后。一年后？哦，天哪，安迪。哦，太棒了。艾莉森打电话说，巴克利，过几个星期你要拍一集，而且戏份很多。就像你在自己家里办派对一样。所有人都来了。太疯狂了。她还说，J·J·艾布拉姆斯在执导。太疯狂了。你当时会想，等等，我得重新安排一些会议。
I'm gonna change around. But it was after we hired Ryan at the very end of season three that I kind of thought, oh, maybe I'll get to be on this like two or three times. It's like we're coming to corporate. He's coming to corporate. Maybe I'll get to be on it. You could see a possible story. I thought, yeah, like, oh, wow.
我得调整一下。但直到我们在第三季末期雇了瑞恩之后，我才开始觉得，哦，也许我能在这部剧里露面两三次吧。就像我们要去公司总部。他要去公司总部。也许我能演。你能看出可能的发展剧情。我想，是的，就像，哦，哇。
Do you get recognized a lot? Do people scream suck it at you? Yes. And then do other people wonder why people are screaming, suck it at you? It's funny. And I definitely have it sometimes. And it's in all of this has started to happen so much more
你经常被认出来吗？人们会冲你大喊“吮吸它”（suck it）吗？是的。然后其他人会纳闷为什么有人冲你喊“吮吸它”吗？这很有趣。而且我确实有时会遇到这种情况。这一切开始发生得更多，尤其是在
in the last three or four years because of Netflix and the show is so much bigger and everything. Andy, do you still work at Merrill Lynch? No. So I left the last season of Marilyn? No, so I left. The last season of the show was when I finally left. Well, you've gone on to do a bunch of stuff now. You're now a full-time actor.
过去的三四年里，因为Netflix的原因，这部剧的影响力变得大得多，诸如此类。安迪，你现在还在美林证券工作吗？不。所以我离开是在美林证券的最后一季？不，我离开了。在该剧的最后一季时我才终于离开的。好吧，你现在已经去做了很多其他事情。你现在是一名全职演员了。
What are you working on right now? Can we tell people where to find you now? Super, super lucky. So let's see. So I get to be on a cast once again by Alison Jones, this HBO show called Avenue Five, which is super funny. And it's the fellow that wrote Created Veep. It's his new show. We're on this crazy, you know, we're on a cruise ship, luxury cruise ship in outer space. But like, it's,
你现在在忙些什么？我们能告诉大家去哪里找你吗？超级、超级幸运。让我想想。所以我有幸再次被艾莉森·琼斯选中参演一部HBO的剧集，叫《第五大道》，超级搞笑。这是创作了《副总统》的那位仁兄创作的新剧。这是他的新剧。我们在一艘疯狂的，你知道的，我们在太空中坐一艘游轮，豪华太空游轮。但就像，
it's just a cruise ship, but it's 30 years from now. So we're in space, as if Elon Musk or Richard Branson, Steve Buehler. Right, right. Had finally figured it out. And Hugh Laurie is the captain of the ship. And Josh, yeah. And Zach Woods is on it. Right, right. He'd finally figured it out. And Hugh Laurie's the captain of the ship. Oh my gosh. And Josh, yeah. And Zach Woods is on it. It's great. Because, oh my goodness, is he so funny.
它只是一艘游轮，但背景设定在30年后的未来。所以我们在太空中，就好像埃隆·马斯克或理查德·布兰森、史蒂夫·布勒。对，对。终于把它弄明白了。休·劳瑞是这艘船的船长。还有乔什，对。扎克·伍德也在里面。对，对。终于把它弄明白了。休·劳瑞是这艘船的船长。哦，天哪。还有乔什，对。扎克·伍德也在里面。太棒了。因为，哦，天哪，他怎么能这么搞笑。
Because I never acted with him. Like, basically he came in as I was in the toss. He is so funny. He's so funny. And he's so smart. He's so smart. He's so smart. Thank you so, so much.
因为我以前从没跟他演过对手戏。基本上他加入的时候我已经在那儿了。他太搞笑了。他太搞笑了。而且他太聪明了。他太聪明了。他太聪明了。非常非常感谢。
Thank you for coming. You guys can find Andy on Instagram as well. And Twitter, you've got quite a nice Twitter. Tell us your handle. I'm at just Andy Buckley. And then on Instagram, I am Andy Buckley 2020. In case I decide to run for an office. Great.
谢谢你们邀请我。大家也可以在Instagram上关注安迪。还有推特，你的推特经营得很不错。告诉我们你的账号吧。我的是@just_andy_buckley。然后在Instagram上，我是@AndyBuckley2020。万一我决定竞选某个公职的话。太棒了。
But just for this year. Just for this year. Well, I am following you, Andy Buckley 2020 on the Insta. I appreciate it. We're Instapel. I appreciate it. We're Instapel. I appreciate it, I know. And you'll have to come back. You'll have to come back.
但只限于今年。只限于今年。好吧，我在Instagram上关注你了，AndyBuckley2020。谢谢支持。我们是Ins上的好伙伴。谢谢支持，我知道。你得再来作客。你得再来。
Yeah, you are. I would love to come back. Do you have 36 more episodes? Yeah. That's, I, I. And we've only really covered your origin story. So there's more to, there's more to talk about. All right, Andy, thank you so, so much.
对，你是。我很乐意再来。你还有36集没演呢。对，我，我。我们其实只聊了你的起源故事。所以还有更多内容，还有更多可以聊的。好吧，安迪，非常非常感谢。
Thank you for having me ladies. And we're back. Hello. Let's start breaking down the Valentine's Day episode. Let's get into it, lady. All right. So we start with a Pam talking head. She explains it's Valentine's Day.
谢谢你们邀请我，女士们。我们回来了。哈喽。让我们开始剖析情人节这一集。我们切入正题吧，女士。好的。所以我们从潘的采访镜头开始。她解释今天是情人节。
This is not your typical cold open where it's a standalone kind of prank or joke. This applies to the story of the episode. We noted earlier her hair is down. She's got her sparkly headband on. She actually says, I like Valentine's Day in this office. Yeah, because we all hand things out to each other. She talks about how last year Jim gave her a card, a hilarious card with Dwight's face on it. It was so funny.
这不像你平时见到的那种冷开场，那种独立的恶作剧或笑话。这与本集的剧情息息相关。我们前面注意到她的头发是披散着的。她戴着闪闪发光的花式发带。她甚至说，我喜欢办公室里的情人节。是的，因为我们大家会互相分发东西。她谈到去年吉姆送了她一张卡片，一张印有德怀特脸的搞笑卡片。太搞笑了。
But then she says that her and Roy are saving money this year for the wedding, so she told him not to get anything too big. Too big, but she's still clearly expecting something. She still wants something. Well I have a few little background things for this talking head that I found very interesting. Yes. So behind our talking heads was normally you could see Leslie David Baker who plays Stanley Arfilis, right?
但随后她说她和罗伊今年为了婚礼正在攒钱，所以她告诉罗伊不要买太贵重的礼物。太贵重，但她显然还是很期待收到什么。她还是想要点什么的。好吧，关于这个采访镜头，我有一些背景小花絮，我觉得非常有趣。是的。所以我们的采访镜头背景里，通常你能看到扮演斯坦利·阿尔菲斯的莱斯利·大卫·贝克，对吧？
At their desks. You would never see Jim behind you during a talking head because his desk is over closer to Pam's at reception. Is Jim in the background of this? Jim is in the background of your talking head. He's like sitting over there talking to Creed. You can see him in the distance. And you know, I was listening to the DVD commentary and one of the things that Greg and Mike talked about was in this episode, Jim and Pam barely speak. Yeah. But they're always in the foreground or
在他们的办公桌旁。在采访镜头里，你永远不会看到吉姆出现在你身后，因为他的办公桌离前台潘的桌子更近一些。吉姆在这个镜头的背景里吗？吉姆在你的采访镜头背景里。他就像坐在那边跟克里德说话。你能远远地看到他。你知道的，我当时在听DVD评论音轨，格雷格和迈克谈论的一点是，在这集中，吉姆和潘几乎不说话。是的。但他们总是出现在彼此镜头的远景或
background of each other shots. That was sort of a conscious thing when they could have one of you in the background they would. That is so interesting because I noticed that in the background of Jim's talking head later, Pam is delivering Phyllis a little piece of candy. Yes, so see, this was thought out. Now, there's one other thing I want to point out because in the deleted scenes,
背景中。这算是一种有意的安排，只要有可能把你们其中一人放在背景里，他们就会这么做。太有趣了，因为我注意到在后来吉姆的采访镜头背景里，潘正在给菲利斯送一小块糖果。对，所以你看，这是经过精心设计的。现在，还有一件事我想指出来，因为在删减片段中，
Oscar at the top of the episode is handing out Valentines. And this is footage behind your talking head. You say, I like Valentines at this office. We hand out cards and things. You see Oscar passing out these little red hearts. Well, it's a great deleted scene. He hands one to Creed. Creed is getting off the phone where he calls a guy Ace and then he says to Oscar, thanks Ace. And then he has a talking head where he's like, yeah, I'm not good with names. I don't know.
奥斯卡在本集开头正在分发情人节贺卡。而这段素材就在你的采访镜头背景后面。你说，我喜欢办公室里的情人节。我们分发卡片之类的东西。你看到奥斯卡在分发这些小红心。好吧，这是一个很棒的删减片段。他递给克里德一个。克里德当时刚挂掉电话，他在电话里叫一个人王牌（Ace），然后他对奥斯卡说，谢啦，王牌。接着他有一个采访镜头，大意是，好吧，我不擅长记名字。我不知道。
He doesn't know people's names. So that was actually a scene that then they repurposed and used for the backdrop of your talking head. Oh my gosh, that is a great catch. Yeah, and then I think just before we get into this episode, I would love to give a little props to the party planning committee because you know they were in charge of decorating the office.
他不知道别人的名字。所以这实际上是一个场景，后来被重新利用，用作你采访镜头背景。哦，天哪，这个细节抓得太棒了。是的，然后我想在进入这一集之前，我很想向派对策划委员会致以小小的敬意，因为你知道他们负责办公室的装饰。
Yeah. Did you see all the Valentine stuff? I did. Fan catch from Izzy Garagin. She said around 22 seconds Pam has a football plush on her desk. But I noticed that she has Valentine's Day themed candy. She has a cup of pens and a Valentine's Day cup on the top of her desk. And the cups are even sort of like red pens. Yes. And then she even had, there's all these like
对。你看到所有的情人节装饰了吗？我看到了。来自伊兹·加拉金的粉丝捕捉。她说大约在22秒时，潘的桌上有一个美式橄榄球毛绒玩具。但我注意到她有情人节主题的糖果。她的桌上有个笔筒，还有一个情人节杯子。杯子甚至有点像红色的笔。是的。然后她甚至还有，有所有这些
decorations on the front of reception. She's got like a Valentine's Day poster and there's a heart-shaped candy dish. There's red jelly beans. There's like a little squishy heart dude on top of the jelly beans. Over by accounting, there's heart garland. There's a heart poster. There's some heart garland over on the supply cabinet. So the ladies really, they went all out. By all out, they put up two posters.
前台正面的装饰。她有个类似情人节海报的东西，还有一个心形糖果盘。有红色果冻豆。果冻豆上面还有一个软乎乎的心形小玩偶。会计那边有心形花环。有一张心形海报。传真柜上还有一些心形花环。所以女士们真的是全力以赴了。所谓全力以赴，就是她们贴了两张海报。
It's still within their budget. But it was fairly decorated, I will say. I noticed as well. All right, so next up, Phyllis gets a giant bouquet of roses. Did you catch the card? It made me laugh out loud. No, what was it? The flowers are from Bob Vance, fans refrigeration.
这仍然在他们的预算之内。不过装饰得相当不错，我得承认。我也注意到了。好吧，接下来，菲利斯收到了一大束玫瑰花。你注意到那张卡片了吗？把我逗得哈哈大笑。没有，写了什么？花是鲍勃·万斯（万斯冷气公司）送的。
Oh yes, yes, yes. I did catch that, yes. Just that Bob Vance fans refrigeration was part Refrigeration was part of the card. Was part of the card. That does make me laugh. I don't know about you, but my husband, when he gives me a gift, like his card, skills, babe, I love you.
哦，对，对，对。我确实注意到了，是的。仅仅是鲍勃·万斯（万斯冷气公司）作为落款的一部分。作为落款的一部分。这确实让我笑了。不知道你们怎么样，我丈夫送我礼物时，他的卡片技能，宝贝，我爱你。
Okay, first of all, I appreciate the thought, but for Valentine's, his card said, to my wife from your husband. And it was like flowers and it was really sweet, but that's all the card said. So we find out now that Michael is heading to New York to do a presentation about the Scranton branch for the new CFO.
好吧，首先，我很感激他的心意，但对于情人节，他的卡片上写着，致我的妻子，来自你的丈夫。就像是花，真的很甜蜜，但卡片上就写了这些。所以我们现在发现迈克尔正前往纽约，去向新首席财务官做关于斯克兰顿分公司的报告。
And we know this is important because there have been rumors of downsizing. And so Michael has to really prove the worth of this branch so that no one gets fired. In this scene, he packs his passport. For a two and a half hour drive, guys. For a drive. It's a two and a half hour drive.
我们知道这很重要，因为一直有关于裁员的传言。所以迈克尔必须真正证明这个分公司的价值，这样才没有人会被解雇。在这个场景里，他打包了他的护照。去一个两个半小时车程的地方，伙计们。去开车。那是两个半小时的车程。
Not even flying. Not going across the border. Nope. Passport. Got it. Dwight asks if he's excited to see Jan because it is Valentine's Day. And then Michael has a talking head where he says, I would have to be a raving lunatic to try to talk to Jan about what happened between us. Her words, not mine.
甚至都不是坐飞机。又不是过境。不用。护照。带上了。德怀特问他见到简高不高兴，因为今天是情人节。然后迈克尔有个采访镜头，他说，我得是个彻头彻尾的疯子，才会试图跟简谈论我们之间发生过的事。原话，不是我说的。
She sent me an email this morning. I loved that. I loved that so much. Also, did you notice right after his passport, Dwight Handsome, what looks like, it looks like a Blackberry? Do we have some old tech, some old tech catch there? Ooh, old tech catch. Old tech catch, I can't even say that some old tech? Some old tech catch there? Ooh, old tech catch.
她今天早上给我发了封邮件。我太喜欢这个了。我太喜欢了。还有，你有没有注意到就在他的护照之后，德怀特拿着的那个看起来像，看起来像个黑莓手机？我们这是抓到一个老科技产品，抓到一个老科技产品了吗？噢，老科技抓包。老科技抓包，我甚至说不出那是老科技产品？抓到一个老科技产品了吗？噢，老科技抓包。
Old tech catch, I can't even say that. Old tech catch. Old tech catch, okay. As Michael is leaving, he asks Pam if he can pick her up anything in New York. I love Oscar's response. Cause Oscar's like the dad. He's kind of the dad.
老科技抓包，我甚至说不出口。老科技抓包。老科技抓包，好吧。当迈克尔离开时，他问潘在纽约能不能给她带点什么。我喜欢奥斯卡的反应。因为奥斯卡就像老爸。他有点像老爸。
He's like, you know, the best gift would be just do a good job on the presentation so we can all keep our jobs. Yeah, and Michael, thanks a lot. Thanks a lot. And Michael's like, me in New York? Oh, I own that city. Forget about it! Yeah. But you have to go back and look at Oscar's face. Oh my God, it's so good. If that's not a meme, it should be. That should be. So then we have our opening credits. And when those are over, Michael is driving to New York. Mm hmm. No need for a passport. Two and a half hour drive.
他说，你知道的，最好的礼物就是把演示汇报做好，这样我们大家都能保住工作。对，迈克尔说，非常感谢。非常感谢。迈克尔就像是，我在纽约？哦，那座城市归我罩着。别想了！是的。但你得回头看看奥斯卡的脸。哦，天哪，太绝了。如果那不是表情包，那就太可惜了。必须得是。接着是片头字幕。字幕结束后，迈克尔正开车去纽约。嗯哼。根本不需要护照。两个半小时的车程。
Don't need it. Within the continental United States. Still don't need it. And then Jim has a talking head where he tells us that he is not dating anyone. And he's just going to have like a party with his buddies. Well, what the heck happened to Brenda? I don't know. He's not dating anyone.
根本用不着。在美国本土范围内。依然不需要。然后吉姆有个采访镜头，告诉我们他现在没有跟任何人交往。他打算和哥们儿办个派对什么的。话说布兰达到底怎么了？我不知道。他没有跟任何人交往。
He left Brenda that ridiculously awkward voice mail. I guess that didn't work out. He's not dating anyone. He left Brenda that ridiculously awkward voicemail. I guess that didn't work out. I guess it didn't. Now during his talking head, you can kind of get a glimpse at Pam's wedding invite list. Yeah, there's a shot of Pam at her desk and I had a fan question about it. Okay, you know, I did a screen grab and tried my best to read every name. Oh, I want to hear what they are. Okay.
他给布兰达留了那条尴尬得离谱的语音留言。我猜那没成。他没有跟任何人交往。他给布兰达留了那条尴尬得离谱的语音留言。我猜那没成。我猜是没成。现在在采访镜头里，你能隐约瞥一眼潘的婚礼邀请名单。对，有一个潘坐在办公桌前的镜头，我收到过一个关于它的粉丝提问。好吧，你知道的，我截了图，尽我最大努力去辨认每一个名字。哦，我想听听都有谁。好的。
Louisa J said, are the names on the wedding invite list characters or made up or based on real life people? Now I was looking at some of these names and part of it looked like maybe Phil Shea had started the list, but it looked like you had added to it during the scene. Yes. The typed list was provided to me by Phil Shea. Yes. The handwritten list are the names
路易莎·J问，婚礼邀请名单上的名字是角色名字、虚构的名字，还是基于现实生活中的人？我当时在看其中一些名字，有一部分看起来可能是菲尔·谢伊开的头，但看起来你在那个场景中又往上面添加了一些。是的。打字出来的名单是菲尔·谢伊提供的给我。是的。手写的名单是
of my real aunts and uncles and cousins. I was gonna say, I saw Emily, which is your sister. Yep. So I was like, as I screen grabbed it, I was like, oh, Jenna just started writing her actual family. I did. Okay, that's what I thought.
我现实生活中的阿姨、叔叔和表亲的名字。我正想说呢，我看到了艾米丽，那是你姐姐。对。所以我截屏的时候就在想，哦，詹娜开始写她真正的家人了。我确实写了。好吧，我想也是。
Yeah. I wrote down Bob and Millie, Jim and Debbie, Ed. Oh, I'm trying to remember all of them. Yeah, you wrote down Ed, Mark, Jim and Debbie. It looked like Anne, which is your mom's name. That's my mom. Yeah. Yeah.
对。我写下了鲍勃和米莉，吉姆和黛比，埃德。哦，我尽量把他们都想起来。对，你写了埃德、马克、吉姆和黛比。看起来还有安，那是你妈妈的名字。那是我的妈妈。对。对。
Okay. I just thought it would be fun because maybe they would get to see their names on TV. No, I think that's fantastic. I would have done the same thing. I'm pretty sure my uncle Bob did write me an email because he noticed or someone noticed and told him. So that was like a fun little thing. I think it's also good that your family has somewhat like common names because like I would
好吧。我只是觉得这会很有趣，因为也许他们能在电视上看到自己的名字。不，我觉得这太棒了。我也会这么做的。我很确定我叔叔鲍勃确实给我发过邮件，因为他注意到了或者有人注意到了告诉了他。所以那是个有趣的小花絮。我觉得好玩的是，你家人的名字相对都挺常见的，因为如果是我
have done the same thing, but my list would have been like birdie. My aunt Thelma, like it'd be like, wait, this, this list looks a little Southern. Let's see. Next up Dwight gets a Valentine's Day gift. Oh, there's a box on his desk. He gets the best gift ever. Yes. He gets a Dwight gets a Valentine's Day gift. There's a box on his desk. He gets the best gift ever. Yes, he gets a Dwight bobblehead, a bobblehead of himself. And we had a fan question. Actually, a lot of people asked, but Kelly Peck and Enza from Chicago both asked,
我也会这么做，但我的名单可能会是伯蒂。我的姨妈塞尔玛，那就会变成，等等，这份名单看起来有点南方特色。让我们看看。接下来德怀特收到了一个情人节礼物。哦，他桌上有个盒子。他收到了史上最好的礼物。是的。德怀特收到了一个情人节礼物。他桌上有个盒子。他收到了史上最好的礼物。是的，他收到了一个
how was the Dwight bobblehead made? So Phil Shea found a Bobblehead maker on the internet, and he had rain posed for pictures in his Dwight outfit, and they took pictures of him from all directions. All angles. Yes. And sent them in. It took a couple of weeks, and they sent back a sample. They were able to make notes, and then they sent the real thing, and they just sent the one guy. I remember the real thing too was kind of fragile, and it was heavy. Heavy.
德怀特摇头娃娃，一个他自己的摇头娃娃。我们有一个粉丝提问。实际上很多人都问了，来自芝加哥的凯莉·佩克和恩扎都问了，
Heavy. It's not like the ones you can buy now online. It's not made out of plastic. And if you want one of yourself, the guy's still making them. Aw, what's his name? Let's give him a shout out. It's bobblemaker.com. Bobblemaker.com made the original Dwight bobblehead.
德怀特摇头娃娃是怎么制作的？所以菲尔·谢伊在互联网上找到了一个摇头娃娃制作商，他让雷恩摆好姿势拍下他穿着德怀特服装的照片，他们从各个方向拍下了他的照片。所有角度。是的。然后发了过去。花了几个星期，他们寄回了一个样品。他们能够写下修改意见，然后他们寄来了实物，他们只做了一个。我还记得实物也有点脆弱，而且很重。很重。
That's right. And it was originally called It's You Small. It's too small. I like that. It's You Small. But yeah, bobblemaker.com. That's where you can get a bobblehead made of yourself. And I went on there and they're really great.
很重。不像你现在在网上能买到的那种。它不是塑料做的。如果你想定制一个你自己的，那家店现在还在制作。啊，他叫什么名字？我们给他打个广告吧。是bobblemaker.com。Bobblemaker.com制作了最初的德怀特摇头娃娃。
You can also get them made of your pets. Oh. Your whole family. He'll also just sculpt your face and put it on a coffee mug like coming out of a coffee mug. That one I wasn't quite as attracted to. I'm gonna just be honest. The coffee mug giving birth to your face? Yeah, but the bobbleheads are amazing. I would kind of like a bobblehead of our cat Oreo. I thought the same thing about Sunny. Oh, we should get kitty cat bobbleheads are amazing. I would kind of like a bobblehead of our cat Oreo. I thought the same thing about Sunny.
没错。它最初的名字叫“你缩小版”（It's You Small）。太小了。我喜欢这个。“你缩小版”。不过是的，bobblemaker.com。这就是你可以定制一个自己形象的摇头娃娃的地方。我上去看了一下，它们真的很棒。
Oh, we should get kitty cat bobbleheads. I want a kitty cat bobblehead. OK, where are we? I had another question about the bobblehead from Dagmara K. Did anyone end up keeping Dwight's bobblehead? Well, I just assumed that Rain got to keep it. So I texted him and he said no. Who kept it?
你还可以定制你的宠物。哦。你全家人的。他甚至会直接把你的脸雕刻出来，放在一个咖啡马克杯上，就像从马克杯里钻出来一样。那个我没那么感兴趣。老实说。咖啡杯里生出你的脸？对，但是摇头娃娃太神奇了。我其实挺想要一个我们家猫奥利奥的摇头娃娃的。我当时对桑尼也有同感。哦，我们应该去弄个小猫摇头娃娃。我想要一个小猫摇头娃娃。好吧，我们讲到哪了？我还有关于达格玛拉·K提出的关于摇头娃娃的问题。有人最后留下了德怀特的摇头娃娃吗？好吧，我本以为雷恩能留着它。所以我给他发了短信，他说没有。谁留下了？
NBC. And they auctioned it off when the series ended. Oh, that makes me a little sad. It makes me a little sad too. And it brought up a question for me. I remember NBC did this big auction of all our stuff. They auctioned off some of our clothes. Oh, there was a big auction.
NBC。当剧集完结时，他们把它拿去拍卖了。哦，这让我有点伤感。这也让我有点伤感。这让我产生了一个疑问。我记得NBC当时举办了一场盛大的拍卖会，拍卖了我们所有的东西。他们拍卖了我们的一些衣服。哦，有一场大型拍卖。
I think they auctioned off all the desks and furniture. A bunch of stuff from the desks, a bunch of furniture, but it made me wonder with all this talk and speculation about a possible reboot, how do they get all the stuff back? How do they even recreate the set if they auctioned everything off? Well, I think that probably doesn't bode well for a reboot. I think people are like, nope.
我想他们把所有的办公桌和家具都拍卖了。桌子上的很多东西，一堆家具，但这让我纳闷，随着所有关于可能重启的讨论和猜测，他们是怎么把所有东西都要回来的？如果他们把所有东西都拍卖了，他们甚至怎么还原片场？好吧，我想这可能对重启不是什么好兆头。我想人们会觉得，才不呢。
They'll have to get boblemaker.com to make another like, no, they have to, you know, get bobble maker.com to make another bobblehead. I guess. I don't know. I actually have a Dwight in Angela bobblehead. And I bought one and rain signed it for me. So I've trained rain bobblehead. After this episode, people started asking for Dwight bobbleheads. And so NBC made a run of Bobbleheads. They found a way to make them. Mass produce them.
他们得找bobblemaker.com再做一个，不，他们必须，你知道的，找bobblemaker.com再做一个摇头娃娃。我猜吧。我不知道。我其实有一个德怀特和安吉拉的摇头娃娃。我买了一个，雷恩还在上面给我签了名。所以我有一个雷恩签名的摇头娃娃。在那集之后，人们开始索要德怀特摇头娃娃。于是NBC批量生产了一批摇头娃娃。他们找到了制作的方法。大规模生产它们。
Yes. And they sold out immediately. All right. So next up in the episode, Michael is walking the streets of New York. Oh, he's so happy. Oh, he walks by his favorite local New York pizza joint, Sabaro. You can only find it in New York. In New York.
是的。而且它们立刻就售罄了。好吧，接下来在这一集里，迈克尔正走在纽约的街头上。哦，他太高兴了。哦，他走过他最喜欢的纽约本地披萨店——萨巴罗。你只能在纽约找到它。在纽约。
It's such a great joke because you guys know Sabaro is a huge chain. You can get it outside of New York City. However, this made me curious about Sabaro. So guess what I found out. What'd you find out, lady? Let me tell you. Sabaro began in 1956 when Carmella and Genaro Sabaro opened an Italian grocery store in Brooklyn that also happened to sell food.
这个笑话太棒了，因为你们知道萨巴罗是一家大型连锁店。你在纽约市之外也能买到。不过，这让我对萨巴罗产生了好奇。所以你猜我发现了什么。你发现了什么，女士？让我告诉你。萨巴罗始创于1956年，当时卡梅拉和热那亚·萨巴罗在布鲁克林开了一家意大利杂货店，顺便也卖些吃的。
Okay. So they had a little deli. They had a little market. Yes. And one of the things that they sold was pizza by the slice. Mama Sabaro, as she was known, had this pizza by the slice, and it became super popular with construction workers, shift workers who needed to grab something in one hand and eat on the go. They became so popular that they ended up opening a second location that was only about
好吧。所以他们有一个小熟食店。他们有一个小集市。是的。他们卖的东西之一就是按片卖的披萨。人称萨巴罗妈妈的人推出了这种按片卖的披萨，它在建筑工人、需要单手拿食物并边走边吃的轮班工人中变得超级受欢迎。它们变得如此受欢迎，以至于最后他们开了第二家分店，只卖
pizza. Okay. Pizza only. We are not sponsored by Spar-bar-row. We are not. Probably because I can't say it. Spar-bar- sponsored by Spar-bar-row. We are not. Probably because I can't say it. Spar-bar-row? Sabarrow.
披萨。好吧。只卖披萨。我们没有接受萨巴罗的赞助。我们没有。可能因为我念不准它的名字。赞助萨巴罗。我们没有。可能因为我念不准。萨巴罗？萨巴罗。
Sabarrow. Not spar-bar-row. Not spar-bar-row. That's a different restaurant. Sabarrow. Sabarrow. Sabarrow. And so since then, though, Sabarrow has expanded into 630 eateries across 28 countries.
萨巴罗。不是spar-bar-row。那是一家不同的餐厅。萨巴罗。萨巴罗。萨巴罗。自那以后，萨巴罗已经扩展到28个国家的630家餐厅。
I'm applauding you, Sbarbaro. Sbarro. So, on their website, it says, quote, you're welcome, world. Well, well, not only pizza slices, but pizza slices with sass. I like it. That's some Sbarro sass.
我为你鼓掌，萨巴罗。Sbarro。所以，在他们的官网上写着，引述一下，“不客气，全世界。”好吧，不仅有披萨切片，还有带着个性的披萨切片。我喜欢。这就是萨巴罗的个性。
That's some Sbarro sass. But I thought it was interesting because the joke of our episode is kind of that Michael doesn't get what a local pizza joint is, but it did actually start as a local pizza joint. It did start local. It did start local. Just not in Times Square.
这就是萨巴罗的个性。但我觉得很有趣，因为我们这一集的笑话有点在于迈克尔根本不明白什么是本地披萨店，但它其实确实是从一家本地披萨店起家的。它确实是以本地起家的。确实是以本地起家的。只是不在时代广场。
So there you go. So next we go back to the office and Jim and Kelly are in the kitchen. I love this scene so much. John Krasinski, you're acting in this scene is delicious. It's delicious. Mindy's acting is delicious. I was like, she's so funny in it.
所以就是这样。接下来我们回到办公室，吉姆和凯利在厨房里。我太喜欢这个场景了。约翰·卡拉辛斯基，你在这一集里的表演太绝了。太绝了。明迪的表演也很绝。我当时觉得，她在里面的表现太逗了。
She's full on Mindy. Yeah, it's full Mindy. This is full Mindy. I want you to know when I was listening to the DVD commentary, I almost like spit out like the water I was drinking because Greg and Mike both go, oh, I mean, Mindy just took over. Like, there's no more Kelly. It's just Mindy. This was a whole thing. Yeah, what they don't know is that it happened last episode. Okay. Well, I felt very validated that we didn't even know that like they totally talk about it in the commentary.
她完全就是明迪本迪。是的，完全是明迪。这是原汁原味的明迪。我想让你们知道，当我听DVD评论音轨时，我差点把我喝的水给喷出来，因为格雷格和迈克都说，哦，我是说，明迪直接接管了。就像，没有凯利了。只有明迪。这完全是一回事。是的，他们不知道的是，在上集就已经这样了。好吧，我觉得很受鼓舞，我们甚至不知道他们在评论音轨里完全谈到了这一点。
That's amazing. Well, basically, she tells Jim that her and Ryan hooked up last night. Yes. And Mindy says in the DVD commentary, she goes, Mike, I really feel like this scene is just like a transcription of a conversation you and I actually had about a guy, which cracked me up. Well, it leads to the very famous Ryan Talking Head. I hooked up with her on February 13th. I know. It's like so perfect.
太神奇了。好吧，基本上，她告诉吉姆她和瑞恩昨晚勾搭上了。是的。明迪在DVD评论音轨里说，她说，迈克，我真的觉得这个场景就像是你和我之间关于一个男人的对话的逐字记录，这让我笑翻了。好吧，这就引出了那个非常著名的瑞恩采访镜头。我在2月13号跟她勾搭上了。我知道。简直太完美了。
All right. So then we head back to New York City again, and now we're going to see Michael in Times Square. You know, a lot of people, he tells you they get to New York and they go to really touristy places like the Empire State Building. But he likes to go to Times Square. He likes to go to the most tourist spot in New York. Which I love. And then at five minutes, 26 seconds,
好吧。然后我们再次前往纽约市，现在我们要看迈克尔在时代广场。你知道，很多人，他告诉你他们到了纽约，会去像帝国大厦那样非常游客向的地方。但他喜欢去时代广场。他喜欢去纽约游客最多的地方。我太喜欢了。然后在5分26秒时，
Michael is giving us a tour of Rockefeller Center. Yes. Where he says, founded of course by Theodore Rockefeller. And he also says that the Rangers sometimes practice there. Okay. I did a deep dive. The Rangers don't practice there. The Rangers don't practice there, but they do sometimes practice at this
迈克尔在给我们做洛克菲勒中心的导游。是的。他说，当然是由西奥多·洛克菲勒创立的。他还说流浪者队（Rangers）有时在那里练习。好吧。我做了一番深度研究。流浪者队不在那里练习。流浪者队不在那里练习，但他们有时确实在这个
Rink and Central Park. Like once a year, there's a rink there. I know this because I have a huge hockey. Yeah, I'm a hockey mom. Your husband plays hockey, your son plays hockey, you're a hockey mom. Yes, we've been in New York when the Rangers have practiced on this rink in Central Park, and it's super cool. It's a thing they do for the fans. And but never at Rockefeller Center.
中央公园的溜冰场练习。一年左右会有一次，那里有一个溜冰场。我知道这一点，因为我是个超级曲棍球迷。是的，我是个曲棍球妈妈。你丈夫打曲棍球，你儿子打曲棍球，你是个曲棍球妈妈。是的，当流浪者队在中央公园这个溜冰场练习时我们在纽约，这太酷了。这是他们为粉丝做的一项活动。但从来不在洛克菲勒中心。
Also, there is no one named Theodore Rockefeller. I did a deep dive on the Rockefeller family, and I could not find anyone named Theodore. OK, I know 30 Rock really well because I worked there. Oh, that's right. I was an intern on the Conan O'Brien show. So were like a bunch of office people. Mindy, Ellie, John. But not at the same time.
还有，根本没有西奥多·洛克菲勒这个人。我深入研究了洛克菲勒家族，根本找不到任何叫西奥多的人。好吧，我对《我为喜剧狂》非常了解，因为我在那儿工作过。哦，对哦。我是柯南·奥布莱恩节目的实习生。办公室里的一群人都当过。明迪、艾莉、约翰。但不是同一时期。
Not at the same time. I'm much older than those guys. I was there the very first year of Conan when they thought they were going to get canceled week to week. Oh my gosh. What do you do when you're an intern on that? Like what is that? Well, there was what does that mean? Well, there was different types of internships. Like there was a writer's intern.
不是同一时期。我比他们大得多。柯南节目的第一年我就在那儿了，当时他们觉得随时都可能被砍掉。哦天哪。当那里的实习生时你要做些什么？那是什么样的？嗯，有……那是什意思？嗯，有不同类型的实习生。比如有编剧实习生。
So when I got the internship, they already had the writer's intern. So I became a general intern. So I just basically got everyone their coffee and I didn't know New York City. So I kept getting lost. I was probably the worst coffee run person ever. Did you get to meet Conan or interact with him as an intern?
所以我拿到实习机会时，他们已经有编剧实习生了。于是我成了行政实习生。我基本上就是帮每个人买咖啡，而且我对纽约不熟。所以我总是迷路。我大概是有史以来最糟糕的跑腿买咖啡的人了。作为实习生，你有机会见到柯南或与他互动吗？
I didn't, and I mean, he would walk past and he was always nice. He would kind of give a nod or away, but he was busy, you know? And I knew not to bug him. Like I had enough like awareness that I wasn't gonna be like, hey, Conan, I'm the new intern, whatcha doin'?
我没有，我是说，他会从我身边走过，而且总是很友善。他会点点头或者挥挥手，但他很忙，你知道吗？我知道不要去打扰他。我有足够的觉悟，不会去说，嘿，柯南，我是新来的实习生，你在干嘛呢？
The really cool thing about Conan Studio is it was one floor away from where they did Saturday Night Live. So could you- You could do a back door- Like watch SNL ever? I actually, one of the people that worked on Conan knew that I was pretty strapped for cash
柯南工作室最酷的地方在于，它距离《周六夜现场》拍摄的地方只有一层楼。所以你可以……你可以走后门……能看成《周六夜现场》吗？实际上，柯南的一个工作人员知道我手头挺紧的
and she got me a weekend job on Saturday Night Live as an extra. So there's a whole season of SNL that I'm an extra and I'm in a bunch of skits. What? Yes, there's a great scene with Chris Farley and I'm like sitting in front of him and everyone was so nice.
于是她在《周六夜现场》给我找了一份周末龙套的工作。所以有一整季的《周六夜现场》里都有我演的龙套，我还演了好几个小品。什么？对，有一个克里斯·法利参与的精彩场景，我就坐在他前面，每个人都太友好了。
Yeah, because all that stuff is happening in that same building. Yeah. That's what's so crazy about that area. And like NBC News is happening in the Today Show, it's all right there. Can I tell you one of the coolest moments? It's right outside the stage doors where we recorded.
是的，因为所有这些事情都发生在同一栋楼里。是的。那个区域最疯狂的地方就在于此。还有NBC新闻、《今日秀》都在那里，全都在那儿。我能讲一个最酷的时刻吗？就在我们录制节目的舞台大门外。
I'm standing in this hallway alone. There's no one in the hallway. The elevator doors open and Robert Redford walked out. Wow. And he was with an NBC, someone in a suit, and they were walking down the hall, and they just walked past me, and I was with like an NBC, you know, someone in a suit and they were walking down the hall and they just walked past me and I was just like, Just watched Robert Redford walk right by Wow, I'm just like a young kid from middle of nowhere, Texas I was just like a really cool surreal moment and there were many of those in my time there
我独自站在这个走廊里。走廊里一个人也没有。电梯门开了，罗伯特·雷德福走了出来。哇。他和NBC的一个穿西装的人在一起，他们正沿着走廊走，然后他们从我身边走过，我当时和NBC的一个……你知道，一个穿西装的人在一起，他们正沿着走廊走，然后他们从我身边走过，我当时就觉得，就看着罗伯特·雷德福从旁边走过去，哇，我只是一个来自德克萨斯州穷乡僻壤的黄毛小子，我当时就觉得这是一个非常酷、很不真实的时刻，我在那里的那段日子里有过很多这样的时刻
That is pretty awesome. So we got a lot of fan questions about this Tina Fey Conan O'Brien business. The first one is from Sarah Marshall, 44. Did production hire the woman to play the fake Tina Fey, or was she just a random person? No, we hired her. She is an actress named Miriam Tolan. She's been in a ton of stuff, including ironically an episode of 30 Rock.
那真是太棒了。所以我们收到了很多关于蒂娜·菲和柯南·奥布莱恩这个梗的粉丝提问。第一个问题来自44岁的莎拉·马歇尔。制作组是雇了演员来扮演山寨蒂娜·菲，还是她只是个路人？不，我们雇的她。她是一个叫米里亚姆·托兰的演员。她演过超级多作品，具有讽刺意味的是，其中还包括一集《我为喜剧狂》。
Season two, episode 14. She has a really funny scene with Jason Satekis around 12 minutes. She plays a woman at a check-in counter at an airline. It's very funny. I went back and watched the whole episode. Oh, I wanna see it. It's really good.
第二季第14集。她在12分钟左右和杰森·苏戴奇斯有一场非常搞笑的戏。她饰演一个航空公司值机柜台的女性。非常搞笑。我回去把那一整集都看了一遍。哦，我想看。真的很好看。
And then we had another fan question from Livy Fitzgerald. Please explain the Conan cameo. Well, you know, Greg and Conan were very good friends. They went to college together. They were roommates. I think some of their very early writing jobs on SNL and Simpsons, they were like, they lived together.
然后我们还有来自利维·菲茨杰拉德的粉丝提问。请解释一下柯南的客串。嗯，你知道的，格雷格和柯南是很好的朋友。他们一起上大学。他们是室友。我想他们在《周六夜现场》和《辛普森一家》担任早期编剧工作时，他们就住在一起。
They're friends. They're really good friends. And so it definitely makes sense that Greg, you know, would want to reach out to Conan if he was right there. There is quite a bit about it in the DVD commentary. But one of the things that really stuck with me that I loved is that Greg said it took Conan 15 takes to time that out. Like he said literally it took about 15 tries and he said, you think Steve gets a big crowd? Imagine Conan standing in front of the building where they tape Conan. Yeah. He said the crowds were crazy, so they were trying to get that.
他们是朋友。他们是非常好的朋友。所以格雷格如果在附近的话，想要联系柯南，这绝对说得通。DVD评论音轨里有很多关于这的内容。但其中最让我印象深刻、我最喜欢的一点是，格雷格说柯南花了15次拍摄才把那个镜头卡准时间。他说字面意思就是大约试了15次，他还说，你觉得史蒂夫能吸引一大群人吗？想象一下柯南站在录制柯南节目的那栋大楼前。是的。他说人群太疯狂了，所以他们一直在努力搞定那个。
And he's really tall. He's incredibly tall. Red hair. He's very, very distinguishable. Hard to blend. Hard to blend. Mike sure said that he wrote the scene with fake Tina Fey as a shout out to her, a little nod to their time together
而且他真的很高。他高得不可思议。红头发。他非常非常显眼。很难混入人群。很难混入人群。迈克·舒尔肯定说过，他写山寨蒂娜·菲这个场景是对她的一种致敬，也是对他们一起共事时光的一点心意
on Saturday Night Live, because he said tourists were constantly mistaking other women with brown hair and glasses for Tina Fey. It was like almost like a joke. They would watch other women like get tapped on the shoulder and it was never Tina Fey. And he said that many times him and Tina would like take a coffee break in between writing and walk outside and no one would stop her. No one would stop the real Tina Fey. No one would stop the real Tina Fey, but they would mistake all these other women.
在《周六夜现场》的时候，因为他说游客们经常把其他留着棕色头发、戴着眼镜的女性误认为是蒂娜·菲。这几乎就像个笑话。他们会看着其他女性被人拍肩膀，但那从来都不是蒂娜·菲。他说很多次他和蒂娜会在写作间隙喝杯咖啡走出去，却没有一个人拦下她。没有人拦下真正的蒂娜·菲。没有人拦下真正的蒂娜·菲，但他们却会认错所有这些其他女性。
And so he said that scene was kind of his little nod to Tina. Oh my gosh, I love that. I did too. I love that. All right, so next we go back into the office and more flowers arrive for Phyllis. Oh gosh. From Bob Vance. I mean, Bob Vance. Not for Pam. They're for Phyllis from Bob Vance.
所以他说那个场景算是他对蒂娜的一点小小致敬。哦天哪，我太喜欢了。我也是。我太喜欢了。好了，接下来我们回到办公室，菲利丝收到了更多的花。哦天哪。来自鲍勃·万斯。我是说，鲍勃·万斯。不是给帕姆的。是鲍勃·万斯送给菲利丝的。
I mean, Bob Vance. Not for Pam, not for Phyllis. Pam is getting annoyed. And you know who else is taking it hard? Meredith. Meredith. She's taking it real hard. She's looking real sour.
我是说，鲍勃·万斯。不是给帕姆的，也不是给菲利丝的。帕姆开始觉得烦了。你知道还有谁对此反应强烈吗？梅雷迪思。梅雷迪思。她对此反应极大。她脸色看起来极度阴沉。
Yeah. Well, then we have this awesome covert scene between Dwight and Angela at the copier. Yes. He says, thank you for the gift. Mm-hmm. And then she says, I haven't gotten one yet. I haven't gotten anything.
是的。好吧，接下来德怀特和安吉拉在复印机旁有一场非常棒的秘密对话。是的。他说，谢谢你的礼物。嗯哼。然后她说，我还没收到呢。我什么都没收到。
No? Now, this has nothing to do with the scene, but I have to bring it up right now because this is the first moment you really get a full shot of me. Mm-hmm. Right? On camera? Yeah. Do I look tan, Jenna?
没有？现在，这跟这场戏没关系，但我现在必须提一下，因为这是你真正能拍到我全景的第一个镜头。嗯哼。对吧？在镜头前？是啊。我看起来黑吗，珍娜？
Do I look a little tan? Yes. Now that you mentioned it. Oh, I am very tan because in my journal, you guys, I wrote, we shot this during the Golden Globes when I got that Mystic Spray tan. Oh, that's right. When we went to the Golden Globes, when Steve won, yeah, you got a spray tan that was real dark. It was orange. Guys, I watched this episode in the next one. I am like orange for two weeks. Oh my gosh.
我看起来有点黑吗？是的。经你这么一说。哦，我晒得非常黑，因为伙计们，我在日记里写了，我们是在金球奖期间拍的这幕，当时我做了神秘喷雾美黑。哦，对哦。当我们去参加金球奖时，史蒂夫赢了的那次，对，你做了一个颜色真的很深的美黑。是橘色的。伙计们，我看了这一集和下一集。我像个橘子一样持续了两个星期。哦天哪。
I mean, I am so tan, it's ridiculous. And they tried to like make my face look lighter. Like I wrote it. They tried to tone it down. I wrote about it in my journal that they tried to tone down my tan. But what happened was my, it just, I just look weird. I thought you looked good in this episode.
我是说，我黑得太离谱了。他们还试图让我的脸看起来浅一点。就像我写的那样。他们试图淡化它。我在日记里写过他们试图淡化我的美黑。但结果是我的，它只是，我看起来很奇怪。我觉得你这集挺好看的。
Well, I'm, I have a mystic tan. Oh. A spray tan. But anyway, when I watched that scene, all I could see was my very, very tan forehead. And next to rain, I look crazy tan because he's so white. But yes, I have given to right. He says the best gift ever. Yeah. And then he promises that he has one for me, which I'm very happy about. And then he clearly realizes, Oh no, now I have to deliver. Exactly. Exactly. He says you'll get something by the end of today. He needs
嗯，我，我做了神秘美黑。哦。喷雾美黑。总之，当我看到那场戏时，我眼里只能看到我非常非常黑的额头。而且挨着雷恩，我看起来黑得发狂，因为他太白了。但是是的，我送给了……对。他说这是史上最好的礼物。是的。然后他向我保证他给我准备了一份，我对此非常高兴。然后他显然意识到，哦不，现在我得兑现了。没错。没错。他说你今天结束前就会收到。他需要
to give himself some time. Yeah. To get something. All right, so then we have the scene where Jim is on the phone. He's making plans with his poker buddies. John Krasinski does such great fake phone. You guys, fake phone. Fake phone is not easy. No, there's no one on the other end of that call.
给自己留点时间。是的。去弄一份礼物。好吧，接下来是吉姆在打电话的场景。他在和他的扑克牌友们做计划。约翰·卡拉辛斯基打假电话演得太棒了。伙计们，假电话。假电话可不容易。不，电话那头根本没人。
I fully believed he's talking to someone and his laugh seems so organic. Yeah. I'm like, John, applause for fake phone skills. Great fake phone, really, really good. And this is also sort of the time in their relationship, if you will, where Jim, I mean, you have a wedding date set.
我完全相信他在和某人说话，而且他的笑声听起来那么自然。是的。我只想说，约翰，为你的假电话演技鼓掌。假电话演得太棒了，真的太棒了。这也是他们关系中的某个阶段，如果你愿意这么说的话，吉姆，我是说，你们已经定好了婚礼日期。
Yeah. It's like all that Pam is talking about really is like planning the wedding and Jim really starts to pull away. And then you see Pam feeling that absence. Well, and remember in the last episode, they got in a full fight about Pam's decision to not pursue her graphic design internship. Yeah. And so I think Jim kind of feels like, I don't know what I'm supposed to do here.
是的。帕姆一直在谈论的真的就是筹备婚礼，而吉姆开始真正疏远了。然后你能看到帕姆感受到了那种缺席。嗯，而且记得上一集里，他们为帕姆决定放弃追求平面设计实习机会的事大吵了一架。是的。所以我觉得吉姆有点觉得，我不知道我在这里该做什么。
I don't know where I fit in anymore. Yeah, and she's getting married. Yeah. Then a giant teddy bear arrives. And it's being delivered by two guys in Vance refrigeration outfits. They were played by our writing team of Jean Stupnitsky and Lee Eisenberg.
我不知道我还能融入哪里。是的，而且她要结婚了。接着，一个巨大的泰迪熊送到了。是由两个穿着万斯制冷公司服装的人送来的。他们由我们的编剧团队吉恩·斯特普尼斯基和李·艾森伯格扮演。
But you only see Jean. Lee got cut out. Lee got cut out. Lee got cut out. It's in the deleted scene. Yeah, they get in a fist fight. Yeah, it's kind of ridiculous. But Jean is the person who says Phyllis Lappin. So if you're wondering which one is Jean
但你只能看到吉恩。李的戏份被剪掉了。李的戏份被剪掉了。李的戏份被剪掉了。在被删减片段里。是的，他们打了一架。是的，这有点荒谬。但吉恩就是那个说出“菲利丝·拉平”的人。所以如果你在好奇哪个是吉恩
and which one is Lee, Jean is in this episode. And they come back later, they're gonna recur and you'll actually get to see Lee. There's a very funny little sort of exchange between Gene and Brian as Kevin, where Kevin's like, that thing's as big as me. And Gene's like, no, it's not. No, it's not. Kevin's like, zip it. So now Michael has finally made it to his meeting. He's done wandering the streets of New York. And he's going to meet with the other branch managers in a conference room. and he's gonna meet with the other branch managers in a conference room.
哪个是李，吉恩就在这一集里。他们后来还会回来，他们会成为常驻角色，到时候你就能看到李了。吉恩和饰演凯文的布莱恩之间有一段非常有趣的对话，凯文说：“那东西跟我一样大。”吉恩说：“不，它才没有。”“不，它才没有。”凯文说：“闭嘴吧。”现在迈克尔终于赶到他的会议了。他结束了在纽约街头的游荡。他要去会议室和其他分公司经理见面。他要去会议室和其他分公司经理见面。
And I just want to mention we said this earlier, this part of it was not shot in New York. This was shot on some stages right there where we film every day in California. Yes. Look out the window. They did such a good job. The backdrop, it really looks like they're up high in a building in New York. No, they're, the trickery is in New York. No, there are- The trickery is so good.
我只想提一句，我们刚才说过，这部分并不是在纽约拍的。这是在我们在加州每天拍戏的摄影棚里拍的。是的。看窗外。他们做得真好。背景板，看起来真像是在纽约某栋建筑的高层。不，他们……诡计就在于不在纽约。不，有……这障眼法太厉害了。
Our set design team was phenomenal. Yeah, but really they are on ground level in a warehouse in a set. In Van Nuys, California. Yeah, kind of amazing. But let's meet the other managers. Yes, I have a card. All right, give me your card, lady. Here's my card.
我们的布景设计团队太牛了。是的，但实际上他们是在加州凡奈斯一个摄影棚的仓库地面上。加州凡奈斯。是的，有点神奇。但让我们见见其他经理吧。是的，我有张名片。好吧，把你的名片给我，女士。这是我的名片。
So the other managers are Dan Gore, who manages Buffalo, yes, by Dan Cole. Josh Porter, he manages Stanford branch, Craig, Michael calls them Craigers played by Craig Anton manages Albany. Yes. So here's a little tidbit about the Dan Gore character. Okay. In the DVD commentary, Mike sure says the quiet guy in the conference room he named after his good friend Dan Gore, the writer Dan Gore. Oh yeah. Dan Gore, who, I mean, he created Brooklyn Nine-Nine, he's a phenomenal writer. And he was a friend of Mike's.
所以其他经理是丹·戈尔，他管理布法罗分公司，是的，由丹·科尔饰演。乔什·波特，他管理斯坦福分公司，克雷格，迈克尔叫他们克雷格斯，由克雷格·安东饰演，管理奥尔巴尼分公司。是的。所以关于丹·戈尔这个角色有个小花絮。好的。在DVD评论音轨中，迈克·舒尔说会议室里那个安静的家伙是用他的好朋友丹·戈尔——编剧丹·戈尔的名字命名的。哦，是的。丹·戈尔，我的意思是，他创作了《神烦警探》，他是个非凡的编剧。而且他是迈克的朋友。
And Mindy sort of chimed in that Mike loved to do that. He loved to put his friends' names in things. He was a Conan writer, he wrote on Parks and Rec, and now of course he's the showrunner of Brooklyn Nine-Nine. So Dan Gore got a nice little shout out in this episode. Yes. So we are meeting all the branch heads and Craigers is an idiot, he's right. He's gotten kicked out of all the strip clubs in Albany.
明迪插话补充说迈克很喜欢那样做。他喜欢把朋友的名字塞进各种东西里。他是柯南的编剧，他写过《公园与游憩》，现在当然是《神烦警探》的剧集运作人了。所以丹·戈尔在这集里得到了一个很好的小彩蛋。是的。所以我们见到了所有的分公司负责人，克雷格斯是个白痴，他说得对。他被奥尔巴尼所有的脱衣舞俱乐部赶出来了。
Very proud of that. If we find out and then he starts insulting Jan. Yeah. Yeah. He says. He calls her the B word. He does. And Michael comes to her defense.
对此感到非常自豪。如果我们发现……然后他开始侮辱简。是的。是的。他说。他叫她那个B开头的词。他确实说了。而迈克尔站出来为她辩护。
He says, oh, come on now, come on now. And he stands up for her first by saying, that's my girlfriend. Oh boy. And then he backpedals and says, I mean, we hooked up. And then Josh Porter's like, you hooked up with Jan? And now he's in it. He spilled the beans. Dang it, Michael.
他说，哦，得了吧，得了吧。他首先通过说“那是我的女朋友”来维护她。噢，天哪。然后他又改口说，我是说，我们有一腿。然后乔什·波特就说，你跟简有一腿？现在他卷进去了。他把秘密全抖出来了。该死，迈克尔。
Michael. He's only beans. Dang it, Michael. Michael. He's only been there like five minutes. Yeah, he's been in a room with these people for five minutes and he's already told everyone that he's hooked up with Jan. With their boss. Yeah. Oh, Michael.
迈克尔。他才去那儿五分钟。是的，他在一个房间里跟这些人待了五分钟，就己经向所有人宣布他跟简有一腿了。和他们的老板。是的。哦，迈克尔。
And then it's like crickets in the room. All right, well, maybe we should take a break. Yeah, with that news. On that news, Michael has just spilled the beans and we'll be right back. We'll be back. Because one of my favorite scenes is happening back at the office.
然后房间里鸦雀无声。好吧，也许我们该休息一下。是的，带着这个消息。带着这个消息，迈克尔刚刚把秘密抖了出来，我们马上回来。我们会回来的。因为我最喜欢的场景之一就要在办公室上演了。
Yeah. We need to talk about it. It's good stuff. It's good. MUSIC Okay, so we're back. You guys, I have to talk about this scene between Dwight and Pam in the break room.
是的。我们得聊聊这个。这很棒。很不错。音乐好了，我们回来了。伙计们，我必须聊聊休息室里德怀特和帕姆的这场戏。
Yeah. I loved it so much, Jenna. I rewound and watched it a few times. Oh gosh, how did you get through it without laughing? How your reaction when he says like a ham? Yeah. And you're like, no, not exactly like a ham. Jenna is so funny. I don't even know how you kept a straight face though. My intention in that was like I was talking to like a five or a six year old and I couldn't let them see my real feelings about the things they were saying. Yeah, exactly. We had a fan question from Susie Young 22. She wanted
是的。我太喜欢了，珍娜。我倒回去看了好几遍。哦天哪，你是怎么忍住不笑场拍完的？当他说“像块火腿”时你的反应。是的。然后你说，不，不完全像火腿。珍娜太搞笑了。不过我甚至不知道你是怎么保持扑克脸的。我当时的想法是，我像是在跟一个五六岁的小孩说话，我不能让他们看出我对他们说的话的真实感受。是的，恰好如此。我们有一个来自22岁苏茜·杨的粉丝提问。她想
to know if like a ham was scripted or improvised. It was improvised. Did he improvise a bunch? Yeah. So on the day, we didn't really have an ending to this scene. We had him coming in and asking for advice, and they wanted a button. And this would often happen in scenes, and the writers would then come over and give us a list of options. Like suggestions.
知道“像块火腿”是剧本里的还是即兴发挥的。那是即兴发挥的。他即兴发挥了很多吗？是的。所以在拍摄当天，我们其实没有给这场戏设计结尾。我们安排他进来寻求建议，而他们需要一个包袱。这在拍戏时经常发生，编剧们随后会走过来给我们提供一长串选项。就像各种建议。
So Like a Ham was improvised, but then there were all these other options that were written on a piece of paper. And so we shot all of these things that he said, like like a this, like a that, like this, like that. It was so hard not to laugh. I did laugh at like a ham because it wasn't on the piece of paper,
所以“像块火腿”是即兴发挥的，但纸上还写了其他所有这些备选选项。所以我们把他说过的所有这些东西都拍了下来，比如像这个，像那个，像这样，像那样。忍住不笑太难了。我确实因为“像块火腿”这句话笑场了，因为它不在纸上，
so I was not expecting it. You didn't see it coming. No, no. So that my response is definitely like take four or five because I remember everyone just lost it when he said it. And then they were like, okay, wait, that's good. That's good. That's the one we want.
所以我完全没预料到。你没料到他会这么说。不，没有。所以我的反应绝对是第四或第五条，因为我记得当他说出那句话时，大家都笑崩了。然后他们就说，好吧，等等，这个好。这个好。这就是我们要的那一句。
And so then they were like, pull it together and do it again. Do it again. Okay. I have a question for you. When he says shut up, I know exactly what to do. Was that improvised? That I don't remember. I don't remember because I do think that that final look
然后他们就说，收敛一下，再来一条。再来一条。好的。我有个问题要问你。当他说“闭嘴，我知道该怎么做”时。那是即兴发挥的吗？这个我不记得了。我不记得了，因为我的确觉得那个最后的眼神
to camera was, that was some direction I was given, which is like, I know the camera's out there. Yeah. And your look to camera's like, can this day get any worse? Like so weird. I'm not getting any gifts. No. Jim has barely acknowledged me. And Dwight just asked for my help and then told me to shut up.
看向镜头，那是导演给我的走位指示，就是像在说，我知道镜头在那儿。是的。你看着镜头的眼神就像在说，这一天还能再糟糕一点吗？感觉太诡异了。我什么礼物都没收到。不。吉姆几乎没有理我。而德怀特先是找我帮忙，然后又让我闭嘴。
I also love when Rain, how Rain responds to me saying like, she's a little like tightly wound. Oh gosh. Yeah. He like chose to be like turned on by it. So gross. Kind of creepy. Did you notice how many times we were in scenes in the break room in the kitchen?
我也很喜欢雷恩，雷恩对我说“她有点过于紧绷”时的反应。哦天哪。是的。他居然选择对这种特质感到兴奋。太恶心了。有点让人毛骨悚然。你有没有注意到我们在休息室和厨房拍了多少场戏？
Like in this episode, we're in quite a few, I think we have like three break room scenes, two kitchen scenes. So it's interesting, and I don't know if that's cause they were constantly trying to keep Jim and Pam apart or there were these secret conversations about relationships. But I feel like this was a very interesting episode
比如在这集里，我们拍了好几场，我觉得我们大概拍了三场休息室的戏，两场厨房的戏。所以这很有趣，我不知道这是否是因为他们一直在试图让吉姆和帕姆保持距离，或者这里有一些关于恋情的秘密对话。但我觉得这是一集非常有趣的剧集
for that reason because a lot of the scenes don't actually happen in the bullpen. Yeah, they're not at our desks this time. Yeah, so Jim is in the break room with Kelly and he's kind of trying to give her advice. He's really just trying to eat his bag of chips. He tells her to take it slow and then Ryan walks in. And she asked him out in front of Jim and John's. The way John played this moment, like he's like, not in front of me.
出于这个原因，因为很多场景实际上并没有在大办公区发生。是的，这次他们不在我们的办公桌旁。是的，所以吉姆在休息室里和凯利在一起，他试图给她一些建议。他其实只是想吃他的薯片。他告诉她慢慢来，然后瑞恩走了进来。她在吉姆面前约了他。约翰处理这一刻的方式，就像是，别当着我的面。
Oh, he's like, oh, no, not while I'm here. No, please. Oh, so good. But Ryan shoots her down. He says, I can't. I have plans with friends. And I can't. It's so cringy. And she's like, oh, yeah. Yeah.
哦，他就像是，哦，不，别在我在这儿的时候。不，拜托。哦，太棒了。但瑞恩拒绝了她。他说，我不能。我有朋友约好了。我不能。太尴尬了。然后她说，哦，好吧。是的。
Yeah, no, no, no, no, no problem. No problem. Yeah. Oh, and Jim is just sitting there. And I can't. It's so cringy with a giant 7-Eleven Supergulp, and I'm always like, What's in there? What's in there? Why are you nursing on that 7-Eleven Supergulp all day? Well, I used to do an opposite thing in college. So I was not a big drinker, but I wanted to go to the parties and not be judged.
是的，不，不，不，没问题。没问题。是的。哦，而吉姆就坐在那儿。我不能。这太尴尬了，手里拿着一杯巨大的7-Eleven超大杯饮料，我总是想问，那里面是什么？那里面是什么？你为什么一整天都在喝那杯7-Eleven超大杯？嗯，我上大学时做过相反的事情。所以我不怎么喝酒，但我又想去参加派对，还不想遭人评判。
So you'd bring a Supergulp full of like soda? I would bring a red solo cup full. Your own solo cup to the party? I had my own red solo cup. And then I would put something non-alcoholic in it. And you'd be like, I'm good. I've got my drink. Yeah, I got it.
所以你会带一杯装满苏打水的超大杯？我会带一个红色的塑料马克杯，里面装满……你自己带红色马克杯去派对？我有自己的红色马克杯。然后我会在里面装点无酒精的东西。你就会说，我很好。我有我的饮料。是的，我有了。
I'm good. I'm fine. I don't need to get drunk on whatever you're handing out, weird frat boy party. Oh my gosh. You have solo cup. Oh my gosh. Yeah. Have solo cup, we'll travel. Yeah, exactly.
我很好。我挺好的。我才不需要在你们这些奇怪的兄弟会派对上发的东西里喝醉呢。哦天哪。你有马克杯。哦天哪。是的。有红杯在手，走遍天下都不怕。是的，没错。
So I did like a opposite thing. A reverse, yeah. A reverse Meredith. Should we go back to New York and meet our CFO, David Wallace? Yeah, cause it's about to really go south. And also, I mean, oh God. Yeah.
所以我做了一件相反的事。反其道而行之，是的。反向梅雷迪思。我们是不是该回纽约去见见我们的首席财务官大卫·华尔士了？是的，因为事情马上要急转直下了。而且，我的天。是的。
How funny is faces of Scranton? I don't want to jump ahead, but that is some funny shiitake. Yeah, it's time for the presentations. Josh Porter gives a nice, normal presentation. Yes. Yes. And you know, in the DVD commentary, Mike Scherr said, it was really important to him that you saw a range of competence in the branch managers.
《斯克兰顿面孔》有多搞笑？我不想剧透，但那真的是些搞笑的屎太奇。是的，该做展示了。乔什·波特做了一个不错又正常的展示。是的。是的。而且你知道，在DVD评论音轨里，迈克·舒尔说，让他看到分公司经理们能力范围的多样性非常重要。
A range of competence. Yes, I'm paraphrasing. I don't know that he said that exactly. But like Josh Porter is on it. He's got his presentation. He's got it down. And then you have, you know, Michael's kind of somewhere in the middle. Yeah. Because he does actually have a binder. Yeah. And then you have Craig who didn't prepare it all. Right. And Dan, we don't get to see. Oh, well, actually, he's sort of finishing his and he goes, and that's how we're doing it or whatever. Yeah. I think Mike was saying it was important that they wanted to show that that although Michael Scott does this crazy video, that he also did come prepared.
能力的多样性。是的，我是意译的。我不知道他是不是原话这么说的。但就像乔什·波特掌控全局。他的展示做得很棒。他胸有成竹。然后你又有，你知道的，迈克尔处于中间水平。是的。因为他确实有个活页夹。是的。然后你又有克雷格，他根本没做准备。对。还有丹，我们没看到他的。哦，好吧，其实他算是在做收尾，他说，这就是我们的做法云云。是的。我想迈克是说，他们想展示的是，尽管迈克尔·斯科特搞了这个疯狂的视频，但他确实也是做好了准备才来的。
He's not, he's not like Craig. He's not completely incompetent. Yes. Well, let's talk about that video. When Michael starts his presentation, he presents Faces of Scranton, which is a video of the people at the Scranton branch set to With or Without You by you two. Yeah. How could we afford that? And it's we must have blown our whole budget on that song. And it's like not in slow motion, but it's not in regular motion. It's a little slowed down.
他不是，他不像克雷格。他并非完全不胜任。是的。好吧，我们来聊聊那个视频。迈克尔开始做展示时，他放映了《斯克兰顿面孔》，这是一个配上U2乐队的《With or Without You》的斯克兰顿分公司员工视频。是的。我们怎么负担得起那个？我们肯定把整个预算都花在那首歌上了。而且它不是慢动作，但也不是正常速度。稍微放慢了一点。
It's a little slowed down. So everyone is like blinking real slow, waving the camera real slow. Walking slowly, sitting slowly. We had a fan question from Rebecca Hevin. She said, did Steve actually film the footage from the business meeting presentation video? Did you get any intel when you were talking with Randall about how they made Faces of Scranton?
稍微放慢了一点。所以每个人看起来都在慢动作眨眼，慢动作冲镜头挥手。慢动作走路，慢动作坐着。我们有一个来自丽贝卡·海文的粉丝提问。她说，商务会议展示视频里的镜头真的是史蒂夫拍的吗？你和兰德尔聊天时，有没有打听到他们是怎么制作《斯克兰顿面孔》的内幕？
Randall said that he filmed that specifically for this episode. Okay. It wasn't pieced together from other footage. That was my question. Yeah. That he actually filmed that. I noticed I'm wearing the wardrobe from Boys and Girls. Did you notice? I did not. Yeah. So I think we filmed it the week prior because I'm in my Boys and Girls wardrobe, which we filmed the episode before this one. And you're not spray tan. I'm not tan. In faces of scram. I'm not tan and I'm in my pink sweater with my low ponytail.
兰德尔说那是他专门为这一集拍摄的。好的。并不是从别的素材里东拼西凑剪出来的。这就是我的问题。是的。他是真的拍了那些素材。我注意到我穿着《男女之间》那一集的戏服。你注意到了吗？我没有。是的。所以我想我们是前一周拍的，因为我穿着《男女之间》的戏服，那是我们拍这一集之前的那一集。而且你没有做喷雾美黑。我没有晒黑。在《斯克兰顿面孔》里。我没有晒黑，穿着我的粉色毛衣扎着低马尾。
Oh, okay. Yeah. So that, I think we filmed it right before, but I'm happy to hear that because my memory was that those shots were scripted in the script, that there was a description of Faces of Scranton. Particularly I remember getting those shots of him over my shoulder with the, like the dialogue was scripted and then there were suggestions of what the shots should be.
哦，好吧。是的。所以，我想我们是在那之前不久拍的，但我很高兴听到这个，因为我的记忆是，那些镜头在剧本里是写出来的，剧本对《斯克兰顿面孔》有描述。特别是，我记得拍到他在我肩膀上方拿着那些……就像对话是写好的，然后对应该拍什么镜头有一些建议。
Definitely. The whole scene where I have the brownies and I'm looking kind of sour at him, that was all planned out. Phil Shea had the brownies, the whole thing. So yeah, Randall shot that specifically for this and there were beats that he had to hit. Now the great thing is you guys if you love it go to the DVD extras because there's extended footage. What you see is actually condensed. There's actually more footage of faces of Scranton. Maybe that's the version that Michael submits to the film festivals. Well, but he tells so he's like, but you know what, maybe, maybe it's not appropriate. Maybe not. Maybe he will, maybe he won't. Maybe he won't. He's not sure. The video doesn't go over well.
绝对是的。我拿着布朗尼蛋糕、对他露出嫌弃表情的整场戏，全都是计划好的。菲尔·谢伊准备了布朗尼蛋糕，整个过程都是。所以是的，兰德尔是专门为这个拍的，而且他必须踩中节奏。现在最棒的是，伙计们，如果你喜欢，去看DVD花盘，里面有加长片段。你看到的其实是精简版。实际上还有更多《斯克兰顿面孔》的素材。也许那是迈克尔提交给电影节的版本吧。好吧，但他告诉……所以他说，但你知道吗，也许，也许这不太合适。也许不合适。也许他会，也许他不会。也许他不会。他不确定。这个视频反响不太好。
They're stunned. Oh my God, Melora's reaction is Jan. It's just amazing. Melora, you crushed it. I loved it. So David just asked for his sales numbers. He's like, can I just get your sales numbers? And I was really worried for a second. I was like, oh no. But no, Michael has those too. He hands out some little binders. He was prepared. He had binders all ready to go. That's Michael in a nutshell. He's trying to be outside the box. He's trying to tug on your heartstrings and make this is his whole thing. He wants the work to be more than just a binder of numbers. He wants it to be about people. That the thing is, they are his family. Yes. You know, things move at a slower pace. The song is with or without you. It does. It has nothing to do with the workplace. No.
他们惊呆了。哦天哪，梅洛拉演的简的反应。简直太绝了。梅洛拉，你演得太棒了。我太喜欢了。大卫刚刚索要他的销售数据。他说，我能看看你们的销售数据吗？我有一秒钟真的很担心。我想，哦不。但没有，迈克尔也有那些。他分发了一些小活页夹。他准备好了。他把活页夹都准备好了随时拿出来。这就是典型的迈克尔。他试图不落俗套。他试图触动你的心弦，这就是他的一贯作风。他希望工作不仅仅是一册数字活页夹。他希望它是关于人的。重点是，他们是他的家人。是的。你知道，事情的节奏较慢。那首歌是《With or Without You》。确实如此。这跟工作场所毫无关系。不。
Like what is it's like a, like a love song. song. Yeah. And just when he was like, are spend a day in Phyllis's pants, what does he say? Spend a day in Phyllis's pants is not what he says. Spend. No, no. Well he says like, see what it's like to walk a day in Oscar shoes or sit in Phyllis's pants. I don't know what he says about Phyllis's pants.
就好像它是一首，一首情歌。歌曲。是的。当他说，在菲利丝的裤子里过一天，他到底说了什么？在菲利丝的裤子里过一天可不是他说的。在……不，不。好吧，他说的是，看看在奥斯卡的鞋子里走一天或者坐在菲利丝的裤子里是什么感觉。我不知道他关于菲利丝的裤子说了什么。
It's right as she's sitting down in slow motion. I just love it. I hope this gave you a little taste of what life is like here at Dunder Mifflin's Scranton. What it's like to walk a mile in Oscar shoes or try on Phyllis's pants. There it is. Or try on Phyllis's pants.
就在她以慢动作坐下的那一刻。我太喜欢了。我希望这能让你们对邓德米夫林斯克兰顿分公司的生活有个初步的了解。在奥斯卡的鞋子里走上一英里或者试穿菲利丝的裤子是什么感觉。就是这样。或者试穿菲利丝的裤子。
Okay, okay. So he says try on Phyllis pants in slow mo as she's sitting down. Yes. Faces of Scranton and then the very end, great Scott. Mike said Mike sure said that was an afterthought, that he just sort of added that last minute and they made it. But it's so perfect.
好的，好的。所以他在她坐下的慢镜头里说试穿菲利丝的裤子。是的。《斯克兰顿面孔》然后最后，太棒了斯科特。迈克说——迈克·舒尔说那是后来补上的，他只是最后一分钟加进去的，然后他们就做出来了。但它太完美了。
It's so funny, it's so funny, so funny. All right, so now we're gonna go back to the office again after that presentation. And Oscar is going to get some flowers. He, not flowers, he got a plant. Well, yeah. Which I think is perfect. Perfect.
太搞笑了，太搞笑了，太搞笑了。好了，看完那个展示，我们要再次回到办公室了。奥斯卡要收到一些花了。他，不是花，他收到了一盆植物。嗯，是的。我觉得这很完美。完美。
And he reads the card. He says they're from his mom. And I loved his choice of putting the card in his pocket. Yeah. He puts it in his pocket. Puts it in his pocket. Meredith has passed out. There's nothing for Pam. There's nothing for Pam.
他读了卡片。他说那是他妈妈送的。我超喜欢他把卡片塞进口袋里的选择。是的。他把它塞进口袋。把它塞进口袋。梅雷迪思晕倒了。没有帕姆的份。没有帕姆的份。
There's nothing for Angela. Yeah. And Meredith is gonna sleep this one out. Here's a fan catch. At 14 minutes, 45 seconds, Adam West, 84 says, there's a huge week calendar on the wall beside accounting that you can see from both accounting and from reception.
没有安吉拉的份。是的。梅雷迪思要睡过去把这事儿糊弄过去。这里有个粉丝抓包。在14分45秒时，亚当·韦斯特，84岁说，会计部旁边的墙上挂着一个巨大的周历，从会计部和前台都能看到。
It's always there. It's always there. It's a dry erase board calendar. Yes. He said it has always bothered him that they abbreviate Thursday as THUS, instead of THUR. And he said, quote, it breaks my mind. Well, I need to go back and see that.
它一直挂在那儿。它一直挂在那儿。那是一个白板日历。是的。他说他一直很困扰的一点是，他们把星期四缩写为THUS，而不是THUR。他说，引述一下，“这简直要把我逼疯了。”好吧，我得回去看看那个。
14 minutes, 45 seconds. I mean, I know, I do remember the handwriting was a bit sloppy. There is a chance that R looks like an S if it's in cursive. I'm gonna go and look at it. I'm gonna go check it. So you're thinking it's THUR.
14分45秒。我的意思是，我懂，我的确记得字迹有点草率。如果写的是连笔字，R确实有可能看起来像S。我要去看看。我要去检查一下。所以你觉得应该是THUR。
You know what, I'll tell you what, it's not written in cursive. The days of the week are taped out. Oh, I'll- In block letters, THUS thus. That would make me crazy too. Yeah, it's really bothering Adam. That's a crazy good catch, I'm gonna go check it out.
你知道吗，我告诉你吧，它不是连笔写的。星期几是贴上去的。哦，我会……用印刷体，THUS，thus。那也会把我逼疯的。是的，亚当真的很困扰。这真是一个疯狂的绝佳抓包，我要去瞧瞧。
And I think it's just always that way. I can't wait, I can't wait to go check it out. All right, so next, Jim's in the kitchen with Kelly and he's giving her, like, he is being a good friend, actually, he's being gentle and he's like, you know what, he's just not into you. It would be great if he was, but he's not. So you just have to suck it up.
而且我觉得它一直都是那样的。我等不及了，我等不及去瞧瞧了。好吧，接下来，吉姆在厨房里和凯利在一起，他在给她……他其实是个好朋友，他态度很温和，他说，你知道吗，他就是对你不感兴趣。如果他喜欢你就太好了，但他没有。所以你只能咬牙接受。
Both Jim and Pam are saying to others, they're giving advice to others in this episode. Pam gives advice to Dwight and she says something where it's just Pam projecting, where she says, you know, it's just, you want her to think that you thought of her, right? Yeah, it's not what you give her, it's that she knows you thought of her.
吉姆和帕姆都在这一集里向其他人提供建议。帕姆给德怀特提建议，她说了一些完全是帕姆自身投射的话，她说，你知道的，这只是，你想让她觉得你想到了她，对吧？是的，重要的不是你送了她什么，而是让她知道你想到了她。
Right, and that's desperately what Pam wants. She just wants to feel like Roy thinks of her, ever. Ever thought of her. Right. And that's desperately what Pam wants. She just wants to feel like Roy thinks of her. That he ever thinks of her. And then Jim is saying to Kelly, look, it'd be nice if he was into you, but he's not. You just got to let it go. And of course, Jim is talking about Pam. Yes. Yes. And Kelly doesn't hear it.
对，而这正是帕姆极度渴望的。她只是想觉得罗伊想到了她，哪怕一次。从来没想过她。对，而这正是帕姆极度渴望的。她只是想觉得罗伊想到了她。觉得他哪怕一次想到了她。然后吉姆对凯利说，听着，如果他对你有意思那当然好，但他没有。你只能放下。当然，吉姆说的是帕姆。是的。是的。而凯利根本没听出来。
Kelly does not get it. She's like, you know, he invites her to poker and she's like, can I invite Ryan? And the face, the face John does when she says that, is like, come on, come on. Really? All right, so again, back to New York, we go back and forth between New York
凯利完全没懂。她就像是，你知道的，他邀请她去打扑克，然后她说，我能带瑞恩一起去吗？那个表情，当她说这话时约翰做出的表情，简直就像是，拜托，拜托。真的吗？好吧，那么，再次回到纽约，我们这一集在纽约
and Scranton a lot in this episode. This is when we find out that Craigurs did not prepare anything for the meeting because he thought it was more of a meet and greet. Well, he's also just a slacker. For sure. He's a slacker. And he ignores direct orders. I think his performance is so delicious.
和斯克兰顿之间来回切换了很多次。这就是我们发现克雷格斯根本没有为会议做任何准备的时刻，因为他以为这更像是一个见面会。嗯，他也就是个混日子的。肯定的。他就是个混日子的。而且他不听直接命令。我觉得他的表现太妙了。
And he kind of gets in trouble. Jan says, this does not bode well for your branch. And then he throws her under the bus. Yeah. He's like, what? I mean, I guess I'd get better treatment You know if we hooked up like that's what he's inferring right cuz she oh No, with Michael he flat out says Michael made a stupid movie and didn't get in any trouble
然后他惹上了麻烦。简说，这对外景分公司来说可不是什么好兆头。然后他把她推出去当替罪羊。是的。他说，什么？我的意思是，我想如果我也有一腿的话，我会得到更好的待遇，你知道的，他暗示的就是这个，因为她……哦，不，跟迈克尔一起，他直截了当说迈克尔拍了部蠢电影却一点事也没有
Maybe I should have slept with you too. Oh, yeah, boom screech This heads us into the Jan Michael scene and Jan is just so Defeated into the Jan Michael scene and Jan is just so defeated. She's like, Michael, it's like I can't, yeah I can't believe it like you don't understand for the new CFO to find out that I would have slept with an employee, she's like I can't believe you why, why Why are you you? And Michael just says he's gonna fix it. He's gonna talk to David Wallace. And you just see Michael loves Jan so much.
也许我也该跟你睡一觉。哦，是的，轰——刺耳急刹车这就把我们引向了简和迈克尔的场景，简简直是彻底被击溃了。把我们引向简和迈克尔的场景，简简直是彻底被击溃了。她说，迈克尔，就好像我不能，是的，我简直不敢相信，你根本不明白，要是让新来的首席财务官发现我居然和一个员工睡过，她就像是，我简直不敢相信你，为什么，为什么你偏偏是你？而迈克尔只是说他会搞定这件事。他会去跟大卫·华尔士谈谈。然后你能看出迈克尔有多爱简。
He feels so bad. Like I think he finally gets it. He's like, wow, he feels bad. He feels bad, but he still makes a really lame joke. So he's like, and don't call me Shirley. Yeah. He can't resist kind of just being an idiot. He can't resist it.
他觉得太糟了。我觉得他终于意识到了。他就像是，哇，他觉得很糟糕。他觉得很糟糕，但他还是讲了一个很烂的冷笑话。所以他说，还有，别叫我雪莉。是的。他就是忍不住要当个白痴。他忍不住。
Yeah. He's trying to make her feel better and then has to like put a joke in and look to camera. Oh, Michael. So I'm gonna jump ahead to the scene where Michael does go into David Wallace's office. And then we'll go back to Dundermifolin and talk about what's happening there.
是的。他试图让她感觉好点，然后又不得不讲个笑话并看向镜头。哦，迈克尔。所以我打算跳到迈克尔走进大卫·华尔士办公室的那场戏。然后再回到邓德米夫林，聊聊那里发生了什么。
But Michael does go into David Wallace's office and he says, it's not true. I didn't sleep with Jan. I just made a joke. This is all my fault. Yeah, it's a joke. It's all my fault. It was a bad joke.
但迈克尔确实走进了大卫·华尔士的办公室，他说，这不是真的。我没有跟简睡觉。我只是开了个玩笑。这全都是我的错。是的，是个玩笑。这全都是我的错。那是个糟糕的玩笑。
I'm so sorry. And Jan kind of perks up like, oh yes, it's a joke. It's totally a joke. It didn't happen. And David Wallace kind of accepts this. He's like, okay, Michael promises it will never happen again. And all is forgiven. Like, they don't get in trouble. It's okay. But I want you to know that I noticed something on David Wallace's desk in this scene. What? At 19 minutes, 24 seconds, David Wallace has a world's best boss mug. Oh my god. But it's black with white cursive writing.
非常抱歉。简有点振作起来，仿佛在说，哦是的，这是个玩笑。完全是个玩笑。根本没发生。而大卫·华尔士有点接受了这个说法。他就像是，好吧，迈克尔保证这绝不会再发生。于是既往不咎。他们没有惹上麻烦。没事了。但我想让你们知道，我在这一幕里注意到大卫·华尔士的桌上有个东西。什么？在19分24秒时，大卫·华尔士有一个“世界上最好的老板”马克杯。哦天哪。但它是黑色的，上面有白色的草书字。
Nice catch, lady! Yeah, if you freeze frame it. Oh, that's a really good catch. Yeah. Oh, wow. And I have to imagine that that was a choice and that they, that's a very subtle Phil Shea thing. Yes.
好眼力，女士！是的，如果你按暂停定格的话。哦，这真是个绝佳的细节抓包。是的。哦，哇。我不得不猜想那是剧组的一个选择，那是菲尔·谢伊非常微妙的小巧思。是的。
Yeah. That's the kind of sense of humor that Phil Shea has that he gave him a world's best boss mug on his desk. I love that. Isn't that great? All right. So back at the office, Angela finally gets her gift from Dwight.
是的。这就是菲尔·谢伊的那种幽默感，他给大卫的桌上摆了一个“世界上最好的老板”马克杯。我太喜欢了。是不是很棒？好了。所以回到办公室后，安吉拉终于收到了德怀特送的礼物。
Yes. It is a key. Angela, your performance in the scene is so good. Your real is that you get this key and you're like, what is this? Just a key? I feel like I could hear your whole interior monologue. What is this?
是的。是一把钥匙。安吉拉，你在这场戏里的表现太棒了。你真实的反应是你拿到了这把钥匙，然后你在想，这是什么？只是一把钥匙？我觉得我能听到你内心的整个独白。这是什么？
Is this a key? I don't even know what this, oh. Oh. Oh, you're so delighted like you're so delighted. It's so great. I had a fan question. Jenny Zislin asks, was the key Dwight gave Angela for her to move in or just for her to have
这是一把钥匙吗？我甚至不知道这，哦。哦。哦，你太高兴了，就像你欣喜若狂一样。太棒了。我有一个粉丝提问。珍妮·齐斯林问，德怀特给安吉拉的钥匙是让她搬进来住的，还是只是让她在
when she wants to stay there? What do you think? I think it's an all access pass. I don't think I move in. We're not ready for that. But it means I get to come and go now as I please. Yes, I had the same interpretation. That's what I think too.
想留在那儿时能有一把？你觉得呢？我觉得这是全通道通行证。我不认为我搬进去了。我们还没准备好走到那一步。但这意味着我现在可以随心所欲地自由出入了。是的，我的理解也是一样的。我也是这么想的。
And she's thrilled by it. And in the bloopers, one of my favorite bloopers from this episode, they're on YouTube, there was the thought at first that Dwight would give her this gift with a card. Okay. Okay. So Dwight was going to write a card and he wanted Jim's help in writing a card for a girl, for a girl. He doesn't say who it's for. And so he starts, Jim doesn't want to help him really.
她对此激动不已。在花絮中，这一集我最喜欢的花絮之一，它们在YouTube上，当时最初的想法是德怀特会带着一张卡片把这个礼物送给她。好的。好的。所以德怀特打算写一张卡片，他想让吉姆帮忙给一个女孩，给一个女孩写卡片。他没说是送给谁的。所以他开始写，吉姆其实不想帮他。
He gives him a hard time and Dwight's like annoyed. So Dwight is sitting here trying to write this card and Jim is hearing all of it. And they're in the bloopers and it is hilarious. But if you want to see John Krasinski break really hard, watch the bloopers on YouTube. When Dwight writes, you are evil like a hobbit. This is the Valentine's card he might give Angela. And John loses it. So that's a fun blooper moment. Well next up, Roy comes in and Pam is done. Yeah. She's very annoyed.
吉姆让他很难堪，而德怀特觉得很烦。所以德怀特就坐在那儿试图写这张卡片，吉姆把这一切都听在耳里。他们正在拍花絮，简直太爆笑了。但如果你想看约翰·卡拉辛斯基笑崩，去YouTube看花絮吧。当德怀特写下“你像霍比特人一样邪恶”。这可能是他要送给安吉拉的情人节卡片。约翰直接笑到失控。所以那是一个有趣的花絮时刻。接下来，罗伊走了进来，帕姆受够了。是的。她非常恼火。
Yeah. And Roy is like, what's wrong? Are you upset? And she's like, yeah, I mean, I know I said don't spend a lot, but I thought I'd get something. But not only that, the person that fills in the blanks when Roy consistently fails is Jim. Yeah. And he didn't fill in the blanks. Nope. She's filling it more than ever.
是的。罗伊就问，怎么了？你不高兴吗？她说，对，我的意思是，我知道我说过别花太多钱，但我以为我能收到点什么。不仅如此，当罗伊屡次掉链子时，那个来填补空白的人一直是吉姆。是的。而他这次没有填补空白。没有。她比以往任何时候都更能感受到这种空白。
It's magnified. She didn't get a cute little card from Jim this year. He gave her nothing this year. Nothing. Yeah. But Roy tells her, it's not over yet, baby. Yeah. Let's get you home and you're going to have the best sex of your life.
这种感觉被放大了。她今年没有从吉姆那里收到可爱的小卡片。他今年什么都没给她。什么都没有。是的。但罗伊告诉她，还没结束呢，宝贝。是的。带你回家，你会体验到你一生中最棒的性爱。
Your reaction to that was so perfect. Oh my gosh. We had a fan question from Jonia Woods. What is the worst Valentine's gift you've ever received? Have you ever gotten anything worse than what Pam gets from Roy? The best sex of her life. Oh my gosh. I mean, I was dating a guy one time and he got me salsa.
你听到这话时的反应太完美了。哦天哪。我们收到了来自乔尼娅·伍兹的粉丝提问。你收到过最糟糕的情人节礼物是什么？你有没有收到过比帕姆从罗伊那儿得到的还要糟糕的礼物？她一生中最棒的性爱。哦天哪。我是说，我曾经和一个男生交往过，他送了我莎莎酱。
Really? Was it special? Was it from somewhere that you enjoyed Salsa together? No, someone... This wasn't a bad gift. Okay, it was just odd. It was just odd. It was homemade Salsa? Did he make it? No, a co-worker made it. I think the co-worker gave it to him. Okay.
真的吗？那是特制的吗？那是从你们一起享受过莎莎酱的某个地方买的吗？不，有人……这倒不是个坏礼物。好吧，只是有点奇怪。就是有点奇怪。那是自制莎莎酱吗？是他做的吗？不，是一个同事做的。我想是同事送给他的。好的。
And then he was like, oh, I got you Salsa, maybe? Do you like Salsa? I like it okay. It's, I mean, it's like kind of getting like a condiment. Like, here's some mayonnaise. Happy Valentine's. My friend makes their own mayonnaise. Um, it, listen, I tried it. It was good salsa, but it was kind of like, okay, well, I think I see the writing on the wall here. How much longer did you guys date? Not, not much longer. Really guys date? Not much longer. Really?
然后他就顺手送给我了，大概吧？你喜欢莎莎酱吗？我还行吧。这就好比，收到了一种调味品。比如，给你点蛋黄酱。情人节快乐。我的朋友自己做蛋黄酱。嗯，听着，我尝了。莎莎酱挺好吃的，但当时的感觉就像是，好吧，我想我看到墙上的字了。你们又交往了多久？没，没多久。真的假的？没多久。
Yeah, not much. Just a few more months later. Shocker. But you know, I am not like, I don't need a big gift. It's kind of like that thing if you thought of me great. Yeah. But it was just really random. And I really, really think his coworker
是的，没多久。仅仅几个月后。意料之中。但你知道，我不是那种人，我不需要多么贵重的礼物。这就好比只要你心里有我，那就很棒。是的。但这真的太随机了。而且我真的，真的觉得他的同事
made everyone salsa for Valentine's and he basically gave me- He re-gifted. He re-gifted salsa. What about you? I can't think of a worst gift. I can't think of a best gift either.
给情人节的每个人都做了莎莎酱，而他基本上送给了我……他转送了礼物。他转送了莎莎酱。你呢？我想不出最糟糕的礼物。我也想不出最好的礼物。
I think most of my Valentine's days have come and gone without much fanfare. I mean- I love flowers. I do. Flowers are nice. Old fashioned that way. I love flowers. I do. Flowers are nice. Even fashion that way. I love flowers. And you know what? My husband was like, Ange, I am not a mind reader. I am not good at this. If you want something for Valentine's, you have to tell me because I am going to get it wrong. So I just
我觉得我的大部分情人节都是平平淡淡、毫无 fanfare 地来来去去。我是说——我喜欢花。我确实喜欢。花挺好的。我在这方面比较老派。我喜欢花。我确实喜欢。在这方面挺传统。我喜欢花。你知道吗？我丈夫对我说，安吉，我不是读心术士。我不擅长这个。如果你想要情人节礼物，你得告诉我，因为我肯定会搞砸的。所以我只是
said to him when, when we first got married, I was like, babe, just always get me flowers and I'll be happy. You can put to my wife from, to wife, one year it was to Simicolin wife from Simicolin husband, but it was roses. I'm happy you got me flowers. I just like to get a nice card with a little note on it. I think that's why, you know, I married a writer, write me something good and a card and I'm happy. And that's what he does.
对他说，当我们刚结婚时，我告诉他，宝贝，只要给我买花，我就会很高兴。有一年送给妻子的是致西米科林妻子，来自西米科林丈夫，但那是玫瑰花。我很高兴你给我买花。我只是喜欢收到一张带有短签的好卡片。我想这就是为什么，你知道的，我嫁给了一个作家，在卡片上给我写点美好的东西，我就会很高兴。而他确实做到了。
To-wife. To-wife. From husband. I guess very different. That's why you need the flowers. I want the flowers, guys. All right. So now, Pam just so desperately wants Jim to acknowledge her in any way today.
致妻子。致妻子。来自丈夫。我猜非常不一样。这就是为什么你需要花。我想要花，伙计们。好了。现在，帕姆非常迫切地希望吉姆今天能以任何方式注意到她。
And he doesn't. No. He just walks past, kind of taps her desk says happy Valentine's Day. And your little bye is the saddest thing at the end. So sad. I'm like, bye. When I go home, get the best sex of my life. I can't wait. Happy Valentine's Day to me.
而他没有。不。他只是走过去，敲了敲她的桌子，说了句情人节快乐。而你那声小小的“拜拜”是结尾最悲伤的事。太伤感了。我就像是在说，拜拜。等我回家，去享受我一生中最棒的性爱。我等不及了。祝我自己情人节快乐。
Per Roy. Yeah. What is, what level of investment is that from Roy? I don't even want to think about it. And then Phyllis and the enormous bear, you know, the writers just wanted to see her carry that bear. Oh my gosh, we got a lot of questions about where did that bear come from? And I'm sorry, I couldn't get you an answer, but where did that bear come from? I don't know. That's insane. That's a Phyllshade classic. Now in the deleted scenes, there is a there, there's one that is hilarious.
罗伊说的。是的。罗伊的投入程度到底有几层？我甚至都不想去想。然后菲利丝和那只巨大的熊，你知道的，编剧们就是想看她扛着那只熊。哦天哪，我们收到了很多关于那只熊是从哪儿来的提问？很抱歉，我没能给你一个答案，但那只熊到底是从哪儿来的？我不知道。太疯狂了。那是菲尔·谢伊的经典之作。现在在被删减片段里，有一个，有一个简直爆笑。
Michael actually gives all the ladies a Valentine. Yes, so in Pam's talking head at the beginning, she talks about how people at the office hand things out and there's actually a bunch of deleted scenes of people handing things out, including Michael, who hands out a bunch of plastic roses. Plastic roses that have thorns, and then his card says, Me so thorny.
迈克尔其实给所有的女士都送了情人节礼物。是的，所以在片头帕姆的单人采访中，她谈到办公室里的人如何分发小物件，而实际上有一堆被删减的片段是关于人们分发礼物的，包括迈克尔，他分发了一堆塑料玫瑰花。带刺的塑料玫瑰花，然后他的卡片上写着：“我太刺啦。”
Yeah. Oh. That's what we all wanted. And then one other deleted scene before we wrap up this episode, you guys, is that when Michael is walking on the streets of New York, he walks past Devon. Oh, yes. And Devon recognizes him and his ticked off
是的。哦。这才是我们梦寐以求的。然后在本集结束前还有另一个被删减片段，伙计们，那就是当迈克尔走在纽约街头时，他从德文身边走过。哦，是的。而且德文认出了他，气得要死
and kind of chases after him. Yes, because Devon recognizes him and is ticked off and kind of chases after him. Yes, because Devin was now in real life living in New York and doing theater, so they called him up when they were going to be in New York to have this additional cameo. A cameo. And unfortunately, it did not make the cut. It's a very funny deleted scene though, so you guys have to go check it out. And Michael has a talking head about it. That's also deleted. Well, the very end of this episode, Jan catches Michael as he's getting in the
然后一路追着他。是的，因为德温现实生活中住在纽约并且在演话剧，所以当他们要在纽约拍摄时，就把他叫来客串了一下。客串。不幸的是，这个片段最后被剪掉了。不过这是一个非常搞笑的被删减片段，所以你们一定要去看看。而且迈克尔对此还有一个单人采访。那部分也被删掉了。好吧，这一集的最后，当迈克尔上车时，简追上了他。
elevator at corporate and she just says, thank you, Michael. Thank you so much. And he's like, yeah, okay. And once again, he's oddly impressed her. Yes. And he's very calm and he's clearly like, I get it. It's over. It's over and I'm never ever gonna go there again. And then she kisses him. Jan! Jan, you are torturing this man. Jan, you're self-destructive. Oh my gosh. And you even see her look around. She looks over her
电梯在公司总部，她只是说，谢谢你，迈克尔。非常感谢。然后他就像是，好吧，好的。又一次，他竟然不可思议地打动了她。是的。而且他非常冷静，他显然觉得，我懂了。结束了，一切都结束了，我再也不会去那种地方了。然后她吻了他。简！简，你简直是在折磨这个男人。简，你太自我毁灭了。哦天哪。而且你甚至能看到她环顾四周。她看了看
shoulder to see if they're alone. And then she kisses him, but she forgot to look over the other shoulder. But Michael knew immediately, he looked right at camera and he's like, ooh, ooh. And then she looks at camera and she's like, oh, forget about it. Forget about it.
肩膀，看看他们是不是独自一人。然后她吻了他，但她忘了看另一边的肩膀。但迈克尔立刻就知道了，他直接看着镜头，露出了那种表情。然后她看着镜头，好像在说，哦，算了。算了。
Boy, and then that is how the episode ends. That is how the episode ends. It's such a good one. And I have kind of a fun journal entry that I wrote. OK. During this week, I wrote, John and I have a new goofy walk we do when we pretend to be kid sister and big brother.
天哪，这一集就这样结束了。这一集就这样结束了。真的是太棒的一集。我有一篇挺有趣的日记想分享。好的。这一周里我写道，约翰和我有一个新的滑稽步态，当我们假装是小妹妹和亲哥哥时就会用。
Well, you have to explain kid sister big brother, because we've never even talked about that. Guys. John and I, you guys, we would have some downtime between scenes. And we would just kind of hang out and sometimes we'd get a little punchy as the day would go. And John's, when I stand next to John, he's so much taller than me. We both sort of remembered this childhood doll that you could buy that was called Kid
好吧，你得解释一下小妹妹亲哥哥，因为我们从来没谈过这个。伙计们。我和约翰，你们知道的，我们在两场戏之间会有一些空闲时间。随着时间的推移，我们有时会变得有点疲惫和兴奋。约翰的，当我站在约翰旁边时，他比我高太多了。我们俩不知怎么都想起了小时候可以买的一种叫“小妹妹”的娃娃
Sister that stands about three feet tall and you could hold her hand and kind of make her walk. And John and I made up this whole thing where he would hold my hand and I'd pretend to be the kid sister doll and he'd go kid sister and I'd go big brother. Yes. And we made up this whole goofy walk and everything. So this is this is what was happening behind the scenes. Yes. While we're filming. We were all we loved when you guys did Kid Sister Big Brother. That was very entertaining for our downtime. You guys were a good team. Well. So you, you came up with a new walk.
身高大约三英尺，你可以拉着她的手让她走路。约翰和我编出了一个整套的动作，他会拉着我的手，我假装是那个小妹妹娃娃，他会喊“小妹妹”，然后我就喊“大哥哥”。是的。我们编了整套滑稽的走路姿势等等。所以这就是幕后发生的事情。是的。在我们拍摄的时候。我们大家都特别喜欢你们俩玩“小妹妹大哥哥”的游戏。在我们的休息时间里，这真的很有趣。你们俩真是个好搭档。好吧。所以你们发明了一种新的走路姿势。
I guess a new goofy walk. We had a new bit to do. All right, you guys, that was the Valentine's episode. Yes. And next up is Dwight's speech. Another really good one. Really good. And we'd like to thank Andy Buckley so much for stopping by.
我想是一种新的滑稽走法。我们又有一个新段子可以玩了。好了，各位，这就是情人节那一集。是的。接下来是德怀特的演讲。又一集非常精彩的剧集。真的很棒。我们要非常感谢安迪·巴克利百忙之中抽空前来。
Yes. And thank you, Randall Einhorn for all of your insider tidbits. Yes, and for more stuff, guys, don't forget to check out the DVD commentary and the bloopers. There's good stuff there. And thank you so much for sending in your questions. Yeah, happy Valentine's Day, everyone. Happy Valentine's Day. Enjoy your salsa.
是的，还要感谢兰德尔·艾因霍恩分享的所有幕后花絮。是的，想要了解更多内容，大家别忘了去看看DVD评论音轨和NG花絮。里面有很多好东西。非常感谢大家发来的问题。是的，大家情人节快乐。情人节快乐。好好享受你们的莎莎酱吧。
Angela, wait, can you please, I have a new merchandise idea for Office Ladies. It's Valentine's Day salsa. Oh no, that guy's going to crawl out of the woodworks and be like, I think I'm going to cut that salsa. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwulf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher,
安吉拉，等等，拜托，我有一个关于“办公室女士”的新周边点子。就是情人节莎莎酱。哦不，那个家伙又要从哪个角落里钻出来，说什么，我觉得我要切断那个莎莎酱了。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwulf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔，
our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of the show and our bonus episodes Candy Bag, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。想要收听本节目的无广告版本以及我们的彩蛋节目《糖果袋》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用Stitcher Premium一个月，请使用优惠码Office。这一集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。